Не стесняйтесь Говорите как есть ужас на
что я вообще трачу деньги женщина
транжир во мне сидит да всегда начинал
вести доходы расходы Ну как и у
большинства естественно ты всё забываешь
дочка приносит копилку она услышала что
у нас денег нет и она даёт пап У нас
есть деньги
ий 30
минут важно не размер доходов и не
размер расходов а важно умение управлять
деньгами
Я недавно начала играть в чёрную кассу
деньги надо зарабатывать выдержал серию
в 20 я в день терял по 3.700 000
долларов в день м я ухожу
друзья 20 марта стартует программа
наставничество со мной это специальная
программа для предпринимателей и
топ-менеджеров 28 живых и онлайн личных
встреч разборы ваших кейсов мастермайнд
с коуч трекером участие в бизнес-клуб
закрытые коммьюнити и чат со мной в
группе будет всего 50 человек а 24 марта
мы уже встречаемся в Дубае полная
информация о программе доступно внизу
регистрируйтесь Добрый вечер друзья Итак
мы начинаем наш очередной подкаст МБО
подкаст А и тема сегодняшнего нашего
подкаста финансовая грамотность
А до того как мы перейдём к основной
части к нашей передаче Я хочу ещё раз
напомнить что значит гем подкаст ну Ну
во-первых слово подкаст Вы наверное уже
знаете вот что такое гемба МБА - это
слово Взято с японской кайн технологии
это слово обозначает то место где
создаётся ценность ценность для
потребителя это первое значение второе
значение - это то место где решаются
проблемы поэтому мы дали название нашему
подкасту слово гемба Итак гемба
подкаст о чём мы говорим на наших
подкастах Прежде всего я хочу всем
сказать что мы здесь собираем не
экспертов потому что многие люди ожидают
что это такая Экспертная площадка Где
умные люди сидят и с умным видом
рассуждают о сложных вещах нет абсолютно
это с этим не связано гемба подкаст -
это такая лёд лёгкая форма посиделок а
определённых людей которые говорят на
определённые важные социальные темы и
Вполне возможно что то о чём мы будем
говорить будет носить поверхностный
характер юморной характер но в целом в
процессе обсуждения Мы надеемся что вы
выч нете и возьмёте то нужное то что
нужно вам для вашей ситуации Мы
специально преследуем цель широкого
представительства после второго подкаста
было много вопросов Почему среди наших
гостей нету женщин Сегодня вот у нас это
уже есть мы исправили этот недостаток и
поэтому наша цель широкое
представительство и это такая
смесь кухонных посиделок и обсуждений
и такой дружеских посиделок поэтому мы
начинаем сегодняшний наш подкаст тема
нашего подкаста финансовая грамотность и
я хотел бы по традиции слева направо
дать Слово нашим гостям чтобы они
представили себя сами Меня зовут раджан
Я журналист предприниматель блогер и всё
пока
я больши гиров Жас предприниматель
бизнесмен занимаемся внедрением
инноваций в сфере
образования в частности специализируются
на дошкольном образования так Дмитрий
Казанцев Я эксперт в области налогов
налогообложения говорю о налогах простым
языком Ну и Эксперт в области финансов и
как раз таки финансовой грамотности вот
у нас не Обошлось без косяка всё-таки
Эксперт Эксперт проник в наш ряды но я
думаю Эксперт нам сегодня не испортит
ситуацию Бывает же так что друзья
собираются и вдруг кто-то случайно
оказывается среди них экспертом Ну вот у
нас такая ситуация очень приятно
познакомиться
толем есть нула
кубаев я
продюсер кинофильмов Нурлан кубаев супер
продюсер производит супер казахские
комедии Я с удовольствием на них хожу
вот сейчас новая комедия как раз подошла
это бизнес по-казахски в Турции и Динара
вот уже посмотрела а я блин не посмотрел
я думал в Ютюбе посмотрю оказывается
идёт в кинотеатре поэтому рекомендую Все
вы юба да да Ну я у меня Я думаю кто же
ждёт Нет у меня
дома не у меня дома кинотеатр поэтому я
дадада у меня до дом кинотеатр попкорн
есть попкорн все дела у меня дома
кинотеатр и я люблю смотреть тако дома в
хорошем ка 100 человек ц надо атмосферно
смотреть ц можно футбол посмотреть и
дома по телевизору и на стадионе
Атмосфера а там смотри другой жанр
зрелищ когда ты ходишь на стадион ты
общаешься когда ты ходишь в кино то ты
не общаешься ты сидишь и для тебя важен
звук и картинка то есть я с соседом же
не общаюсь там другие тише тише Просто
он намекает на то что всё-таки вы
сходили в кино и Купили
билет ждм я вот прямо жду кто не ходил У
меня
есть не обязательно пойду я обязательно
Всем рекомендую сходить это просто
классный фильм И кстати Нурлан он такой
казахский продюсер который я не знаю
твой рекорд кто-то побил или нет по
кассовым сборам по-моему самый кассовый
ты а До сегодняшнего дня мы были самым
кассовым фильмом человек-паук Вот это
последний который вышел Кто такой
Человек паук не знаю даже не будем даже
говорить мы самый кассо да да но это
действительно прошлом году по крайней
мере его твои сборы прили все даже
не вот я говор по Казахстану Но даже
мировые
ты мировые Итак давайте по личным
финансам первый вопрос для всех
насколько вы сами хорошо управляете
своими
финансами до того как нам говорить Мы же
должны определить насколько мы сами
вообще в этом вопросе плаваем или мы
что-то понимаем поэтому не стесняйтесь
Говорите как есть нанм нужно е
показывать
у кого столько денег Но вы знаете я
сейчас очень активно я взяла интервью
недавно у Тимура турлов и год назад мне
ещё говорили о том что иди во Freedom
Finance Да вот я знаю что в двадцатом
году очень многие люди заработали Да вот
во время пандемии начало там в два раза
Да все заработали даже кто-то там в три
раза я как-то так ну Мне всегда казалось
я гуманитарий что акции облигации это
всё так сложно но когда взяла интервью у
Тимура турлову Я думаю почему я раньше
вообще не пошла во Freedom Финанс и
сейчас мне эта тема очень интересна
потому что я у меня бизнес Да шн я 12
лет Этим занимаюсь сейчас Я зарабатываю
в том числе и на рекламе да то есть там
веду мероприятия но деньги которые я
зарабатывала я всегда инвестировала в
недвижимость то есть там заработаешь
пойдёшь купишь себе Да там или в
рассрочку что ты берёшь и постоянно
инвестирует потому что ну иначе а там
покупаешь себе часы как в прошлый раз вы
сказали Оказывается это тоже
инвестиция Я например да вот Вы в
предыдущем подкасте говорили о том что
вот вы купили когда-то серьги своей
супруги а они там почти в два раза да
подорожали Да но я вот кстати об этом
даже не задумалась и вот сейчас я прямо
увлечена ценными бумагами Я хочу
заработанные деньги в этом году все
инвестировать именно в акции потому что
я просто хочу разбираться в этом и я
понимаю что
я не буду всю жизнь энергичной активной
да и у меня не будет нано столько сил
там бесконечно работать Я хочу чтобы
кто-то работал а я буду просто
инвестировать Это моя
мечтала обычно женщины так рассуждают
когда кто-то работал име муж Да но у
меня нет мужа поэтому я понимаю что мне
нужно самой Заведи Пусть он и работает
може
насколько тебе удаётся
э балансировать доходы и расходы
достаточно ли Смотри я Почему задаю этот
этот вопрос потому что есть много людей
которые мне говорят у меня доходы
возрастают но всё равно денег не хватает
вот насколько тебе это удаётся Ну нет У
меня всё нормально с этим я не транжира
поэтому у меня есть шн бизнес который э
вот у меня есть Прямо KP Да Сколько мы
должны там зарабатывать и вот я честно
говоря когда открывала свой Instagram
свои социальные сети Я не думала о том
что Instagram может приносить ровно
столько же сколько тебе приносит оффлайн
бизнес Да на сегодняшний день вот эти
вот доходы они сравнялись классно и
иногда Мне даже хочется закрыть свой
оффлайн бизнес потому что я понимаю что
ну здесь Я зарабатываю больше Да я
занимаюсь любимым делом это съёмки
монтаж там путешествия можно вообще
просто уехать куда-нибудь я не знаю в
России да и делать тоже самое И
зарабатывать может быть ещё больше денег
потому что там рынок больше но я за то
чтобы всё-таки хранить яйца в разных
корзинах и Пусть это будет то есть
заработанные деньги вот которые Я
зарабатываю я стараюсь вот что-то там
всё-таки купить однокомнатную квартиру
да Э да недвижимость на депозите Я
деньги не храню Потому что я не вижу в
этом смысла Но раньше я открывала бизнес
Да вот один за другим один за другим то
есть магазины но потом наступила
пандемия карантин Я вообще поняла что
это ну невыгодно Да мы это всё сдела
закрыли
иногда вот когда сейчас конечно Вот
рекламный рынок то есть вот мне мои
друзья блогеры всё время смеются надо
мной что у меня слишком много рекламы её
реально слишком много потому что я
слишком много денег хочу ре очень мало
сторисов очень мало сторисов очень мало
сторисов Да в принципе там такой пунктир
но мне это нравится и я вот эти деньги
вот в этом году я настроилась на то что
я буду инвестировать в акции Я хочу
прямо разбира
Ну то есть у тебя доходы доходов больше
чем расход Конечно и ты можешь себе
позволить ту жизнь которую ты хочешь
конечно То есть ты умеешь управлять
своими финансами Я умею управлять своими
финансами и при этом я ещё знаете я могу
поставить перед собой цель доме
заработать в этом месяце там
определённую сумму я буду я точно
заработаю эту сумму ну чем не Эксперт
Поэтому я
считаю я вообще считаю экспертом можно
человека который жит той жизнью которую
себе хочет то есть ему достаточно той
экспертизы для того чтобы жить той
жизнью которую он хочет сверх этого это
я называю личные знания Зачем не надо
копить те знания которые больше чем
достаточный и в этом плане Вот как раз
для наших зрителей Эксперт практически
подтверждённый Так Олжас насколько ты
хорошо управляешь своми финансами я бы
сказал так что я е ученик плане очень
многому ещё учусь с нетерпением жду
курса каен Финансы и я бы хотел сказать
маленько сделать отступление в детство
потому что как раз таки в то воспитание
которое мы получаем в детстве она очень
ну даёт большой вклад в формирование той
культуры управления финансами которые в
будущем то есть человек придерживается и
я сам вот тру не то что трудовую
деятельность моя вобще первая запись
трудовой книжки с 13 лет помощник стора
Я
благодарен в первую очере всевышнему и
своему отцу то что он привил
мне жажду желание зарабатывать деньги
потому что самый первый
пункт увеличение благосостояния - это
зарабатывать то есть если Ну то есть всё
финансовая грамотность она строится
вокруг дельты Это разница между
заработком
и ну расходами и доходами соответственно
То есть если
нету этой дельты То есть если или она
отрицательна не дай Бог да то
соответственно То есть как бы уже Ни о
каких инвестициях чем нельзя говорить И
вот первый пункт То есть это заработать
потом Конечно уже находится экономия это
то есть уменьшить затраты чтобы
увеличить эту Дельту потом эту Дельту
приумножить и дальше как-то
инвестировать и здесь вот я подхожу к
этому вопросу с той точки зрения что вот
я очень много разных бизнесов открывал и
у меня то есть так скажем как и у вас
очень много ошибок которые я сделал
потому что открывая один бизнес я брал
деньги из него вкладывал в другой бизнес
соответственно То есть когда один бизнес
уходил то он тянул за собой тот бизнес
который был более-менее успешен то есть
и я за своё время то есть как бы и у
меня было и такси и радио уличного это
Ну много разных интересных таких
бизнесов но а чередой обстоятельств то
есть они пришли к тому что они там
где-то закрылись где-то были успешны
где-то вот в то время как раз уже когда
выходил uber То есть я понял что нужно
продавать выходить из этого бизнеса но
сейчас на данный момент То есть я а
понимаю что вот эти все инструменты и по
так скажем по своим убеждениям То есть я
подхожу к тому что основываясь именно на
свои ценности Я понимаю что самый
главный пункт до вот этих пунктов
нулевой пункт да то есть это а
удовлетворение то есть довольство тем
положением которое ты имеешь но это не
из тех соображений что не стремится к
большему а из тех соображений чтобы не
было тех отрицательных эмоций которые
забирают энергию которые не позволяют
тебе идти дальше то есть Я доволен тем
положением что я имею но я стремлюсь
дальше и ставлю перед собой очень
большие амбициозные планы и цели на
данный момент То есть я сейчас уже вот
Благодаря А году наставничества я очень
сильно поправил своё положение и сейчас
как раз-таки то есть уже в этом году я
ну в конце прошлого года то есть Начал
уже инвестировать и определённые то есть
доходы то есть они уже то есть ну Дельта
в любом случае положительно то есть и
позволяет помимо тех бизнесов которые
уже не трогая бизнес и уже заниматься то
есть определённым личным инвестированием
Угу Классно Классно Ну тоже Эксперт
Эксперт кро меня все эксперты кажется
так Т мы наберём молодой
человек оставил на десерт на самом деле
мне кажется у него больше всего
денег больше всего доходов А вот куда он
дальше тратит это мы сейчас выясним Итак
слово Диме Ну у меня с финансами в целом
тоже всё хорошо Почему хорошо потому что
лет п
назад рассказывая людям там о всеобщем
декларировании дохо я столкнулся с такой
проблемой что вижу что люди не понимают
что такое всеобщее декларирование там
начинает придумывать всевозможные
истории как прятать деньги скрывать
деньги а я понял что вообще в Казахстане
в целом Беда с финансовой грамотностью и
понял чтобы ну начать об этом говорить
надо начать наверное самому в это
погружаться искать проблему А
естественно начиналось всё сведение
доходов расходов потому что на тот
момент конечно трат было куда больше чем
доходов Наверное каждый с этим
сталкивался ну 5 лет своего опыта я для
себя главное понял что А многие
связывают финансовую грамотность с
экономией А я как бы противник экономии
Я всегда говорю надо считать думать и
вести свои доходы-расходы не для того
чтобы экономить деньги а для того чтобы
понимать что надо зарабатывать больше
денег Ну и как многие Я тоже инвестор
говорю про инвестиции я наверное на том
пути вы Динар то наверное дойдёте до
этого когда ты понимаешь что твой
оффлайн бизнес свой Instagram приносит
меньше чем приносят инвестиции А это
наверно больше наоборот То есть это
третья ступень до которой вы дойдёте
когда можно сидеть на пляже по сути в
приложении покупать продавать акции
активно этим заниматься и это приносит
больше денег вот я наверное сейчас как
раз таки на это Какой пляж лучше Ну я
Тайланд очень хороший инвестиционный
вопрос Кай ПЖ лучши вот ну я сейчас
сторонник конечно именно погружаться в
тему инвестиций потому что там
действительно можно зарабатывать но
можно и терять то есть тут многие
Конечно есть Кто идёт туда зарабатывать
миллионы на теряет всё но тут Важно Вот
как раз-таки балансировать вот эту часть
что можно зарабатывать Ну и риски надо
просчитывать все а и с головой
погружаясь в эту тему всё глубже глубже
Ну то есть ты считаешь что ты достаточно
хорошо управляешь или у тебя достаточно
финансовой грамотности для того чтобы
жить той жи ты хочешь Да я для себя эту
цель ставил как раз таки в момент
пандемии что вот всё надоело и хотелось
жить не работа ради работы там вечно
отставить чьи-то права предпринимателей
всё А уже пожить для себя Вот и делать
то что ты хочешь питаться Как ты хочешь
заниматься чем ты хочешь и вот как
раз-таки пандемия ускорила эту процедуру
что полностью стать независимым от любых
обстоятельств Ну то есть это тебе
удаётся
блин нам надо было в подкаст на самом
при е одного участника у которого не
удаётся
получило
так по прили тех людей которые умеют
сводить доходы с расходами небольшая
Надежда есть то что у него достаточно
доходов Это известно всем А вот
интересно у тебя как с расходами
насколько нун ты считаешь что у тебя
достаточно финансовой грамотности чтобы
жить той жизнью которую ты хотел бы ну я
в этом вопрос не силён честно признаюсь
я не бизнесмен учитывая то что я лет 15
играл у меня ту в комнате Там штабеля
денег только ска Да деньги а я играл 15
лет КВН там не зарабатываешь потом в
телевидении тоже телевидение Ну мы не
зарабатываем Ну последнее то что вот я
занимался это кино вот благодаря фильмам
какие-то вышли там журналах интервью что
я заработал миллиард там тос И в этот
момент я начал уже думать потому что как
сказать раньше я играл как получится
иметь в виду что-то где-то мы выступим
где-то зарабатываем я занимался тем что
мне нравилось но в какой-то момент да
Вот Вы правильно сказали во время
пандемии я тоже уже задумался то что
надо Не то что о деньгах больше думать а
просто уже всё на 42 года теперь всё что
я умею надо это превращать прямо без
эмоции где доход где расход Угу а до
этого честно признаюсь я не скажу что
финансово грамотно бывает иногда за
последние деньги могу бизнес-класс в
самолёт купить и сидеть читать я знаю
что я во цену прилечу и у меня может
быть как этот герой своего
фильма как его скоша Или как это такой
полни
Даша я слежу за настроением имеется в
виду Мне очень Как сказать важно для
меня какое у меня настроение как я живу
имеется в виду Да и куда-то я уезжаю я
там что-то здесь в Алмате что-то не
получается мы с семьёй улетаем куда-то и
я бы сказал что иногда бывает расхода
больше Угу А вот но сейчас и может быть
и такой подкаст Что именно такая
финансовая грамотность тема вот это всё
мне нравится тоже сейчас изучаю
инвестиции акции
а году 111 Марта я был в Англии съездил
на футбол мечта была посмотреть футбол и
я попал на игру Ливерпуль Атлетико Это
последняя игра перед пандемии где полный
стадион был Ау радуемся мне звонят
Нурлан Вы домой не сможете улететь все
самолёты сели я говорю как А я Туркиш
или люган должен был вернуться Он
говорит Нет люган за сел А как меня
обратно а или как меня Туркиш забрал Я в
самолёте думаю и футбол всё закрылся Я
говорю как футбола не будет всё футбола
не будет не то что футбол там самолёты
не то что никто друг другу не будет
ездить Я говорю как А я всю жизнь такой
не верю таким вещам что Да нет не может
быть как мы не будем общаться что ли Да
я такой само лечу я начал думать
если футбола не будет трансляции не
будет значит оборота денег там вот это
это же индустрия Значит кто владеет этим
футболом у него акции сейчас сильно
упадут потому что ну ничего нет ни
трансляции никаких движений Да я значит
я брату позвонил узнаю что кто владеет
вообще всемирным футболом Есть ли кто
какой-то владелец где у него акции А я
сам вобще не разбирался Я говорю кто у
нас в Алмате занимается какой-то го
Давайте звоните Откройте я ещ лечу уже в
Стамбул прилетел домой и мы открыли в
двадцатом году где-то 15 марта Как
называется Какой умный Да не
умный
дамся начало клас во время вхо все умные
посмотрим как выход начало
класса приехали в алмаату уже начинаются
какие-то слух скоро что-то закроют но
ещё не закрыли потом двоих кого-то
поймали Не знаю ещё город закрывается
то-сё у меня уже только что открыли мне
надо перечислить какую-то но сумму Я иду
там в банк в банке там что-то что-то
ошиблись и она где-то 3 дня держалась и
потом обратно вернулась ко мне потом
Наурыз 7 дней тос то-сё А мы нашли этот
компанию эта компания называлась ум Хил
и они упали 340 фунтов то 34 я говорю
надо брать пока мы начали Вот это всё
решать когда мы купили 1 апреля что ли
Он уже стоил 110 за где-то 10 дней Ну
концовка расскажу он в августе 340
вернулся в июле Да но супер Воланда Я в
мае кино должен был снимать и мне ну там
я немного там Купил но всё равно эти
деньги нужны были Я оттуда вытащил и
через 3 дня они выросли шесть раз я
долго так в Стамбуле
сидел Я долго думал Я думаю я же мог
выиграть сем раз я говорю я же вообще
этим не занимаюсь Почему я сюда пришёл и
ушёл я понял что это страх а страх - это
незнание то всё то я с улыбкой ушёл но
всё равно иногда вспоминаю как было бы
Не ну это Гениально Да вообще поняти Вот
такая связь футбол
инвестиции Да это особый
склад у любого инвестора когда любой
инвер проблему он прежде всего видит
возможность и сразу
смотрит как на этом можно заработать и
вот в данном эпизоде Нур нам прямо чётко
вот размышлял именно как инвестор Вот ты
размышлял именно как инвестор что если
это наступит Я
[смех]
эксперт Про
Сказали ты ты достаточны эксперт чтобы
чётко понять что ты не понимаешь
больше на самом деле чем смот Давайте
подытоживая Первый Первый круг это
вопрос такой же я ещё стараюсь так чтобы
с каждого Круга как-то люди получали
какие-то инсайты и в данном случае я
хотел бы особо подчеркнуть какие моменты
вот Динара А И вот вы втроём вот сейчас
решили заниматься инвестициями увлекать
инвестициями Дело в том что инвестиции я
всем бизнесменам говорю вот ну нельзя
путать два стула стул бизнесмена и стул
инвестора и для того чтобы стать
инвестором нужно сначала подготовиться
потому что проблема в том что как
правило большее количество по статистике
большее количество людей становится
инвесторами прямо перед падением у меня
так было с биткоином вот так вот
смотрите сейчас весь январь фондовые
рынки США падают а буквально вчера Мета
Facebook упал на 26% всё падает и я
ожидаю что в этом году будет кризис
потому что а ФРС это основной источник
который печатает деньги он начал
ускоренном в ускоренном режиме
сворачивать программу qe э это э печата
денег по-простому и плюс в этом году
ожидается четырёхкратная повышение
ставок А это значит говорит о том что в
финансовой системе денег будет меньше
соответственно в первую очередь
отреагируют
криптовалюты будут падать и в первую
очередь отреагируют акции
технологических компаний Ну и в
дальнейшем посыпятся
биржи Так что нам делать Да сечас сейчас
не удачное время быть на фондовом рынке
сейчас удачное время инвестировать в
своё инвестиционное
образование Ну можно зайти с небольшой
суммой и учиться чисто для того чтобы
как учебная сумма Как так
поэкспериментировать на кошечка Как
говорится
дол здесь не нужно заходить смотреть
маленькими суммами для того чтобы
почувствовать вот Если вы зайдёте
большой суммой то это реально очень
больно очень больно очень катастрофи
поэтому я бы так сказал мне часто люди
говорят вот у меня есть деньги
инвестировать скажите куда инвестировать
Я говорю Подождите Если у вас есть
деньги но нету знаний то вы первая
жертва как орн бает сказал если ты
стоишь сидишь за карточным столом и не
знаешь Кто новичок то скорее всего
новичок это ты поэтому наличие денег -
это вообще не показатель того что ты
готов стать
сначала знания сначала знания вот я
буквально в марте буду
проводить инвестиционный букем
пятидневный в Дубае А вот там мы как раз
концентрированном виде будем давать
знания как куда инвестировать самое
главное мы научим и каждый человек
заполнил себе инвестиционную декларацию
Что такое инвестиционная Декларация это
Это его
психотип очень сильно ваш темперамент и
психотип влияет на принятие
инвестиционных решений очень сильно Если
Вы холерик то в каком рынке Вы можете
работать в каком нельзя Если вы
сангвиник или флегматик и так далее есть
инвестиционный процесс который разделён
у нас на этапы и в зависимости от
темперамента человека в зависимости от
возраста
человека нет гороскоп не влияет в
зависимости от целей и так далее поэтому
мой совет просто Будьте осторожны
касательно инвестиций теперь то что
касается лжа говорил две вещи я хорошо
хочу именно пролить свет
первое моё
дополнение в управлении финансами
существует На самом деле три процесса
первое процесс - это доходы второй
процесс расходы и третий процесс
управление финансами это другое потому
что некоторые люди говорят я доходы
наращиваю А у меня всё равно денег не
хватает а некоторые говорят я экономлю А
мне всё равно денег не хватает
а Весь секрет в том что они неправильно
управляют финансами поэтому управление
это отдельный тип деятельности это
отдельный процесс есть процесс по
увеличению доходов процесс по сокращению
расходов и есть процесс по управлению
деньгами Вот это очень хотел бы акцент
сделать
иты сказал
Вот это причина нашего
недовольства нетерпения это является
причиной того что нам постоянно не
хватает денег а вот в принципе если по
первому раунду
Давайте можно вопрос вот А вот это я
считаю Думаю что будет полезно тоже
людям вы говорите вот два стула нельзя
путать то есть стул бизнесмена и стул
инвестора Но есть же очень много людей
которые и на двух стульях сидят То есть
это до какого-то периода нужно или же то
да Смотрите дело в том что можно сидеть
на двух стульях до определённого периода
А пока вы не придёте в точку принятия
решений У меня есть курс называется
принятия решений в условиях
неопределённости недостатка или
переизбытка информации и противодействия
курс называется так вот Существует точка
принятия решений Почему ты приходишь в
эту точку принять решения Почему ты
вынужден принимать решения и это
касается не только инвестиционных
решений любых решений в вашей жизни
Любой человек приходит в точку принятия
решения по одной простой причине из-за
дефицита ресурсов не нехватка ресурсов
нехватка ресурсов когда я принимаю
решение пойти сегодня потусоваться с
друзьями либо дома сидеть а у меня
недостаток ресурсов меня же не двое я
один соответственно я должен либо там
либо там значит должен принять решение
когда должен принять решение одеть мне
синюю рубашку либо жёлтую
майку опять-таки я должен либо это либо
это то есть нехватка ресурсов э и то же
самое когда ты вырастает до
определённого периода если у тебя
внимания достаточно чтобы заниматься
инвестициями и бизнесом а это как
правило на низком уровне тебе не надо
принимать решени Но как только твой
бизнес вырастет либо объём твоих
инвестиций вырастет у тебя уже внимания
не будет хватать и ты встанешь в позицию
когда ты должен принять решение либо ты
инвестор либо бизнесмен Иначе если вы
будете сидеть на двух стульях
параллельно то не ждите выдающихся
результатов Вы всю жизнь будете
средненький бизнесменом и средненький
небес Почем Я ухожу
Поэтому если хотите стать обращайтесь ко
мне хорошим инвестором Тода надо
заниматься только инвестициями Если
хотите стать хорошим бизнесменом надо
заниматься только бизнесменом ч А разве
Вот вы говорите что сейчас всё будет
падать это разве не время покупать а
Хороший вопрос время покупать когда всё
упало А надоть когда когда всё будет
падать когда надо ть где дно Да поэтому
здесь вопрос Я считаю так что по
фондовому рынку по инвестициям надо быть
крайне крайне осторожным особенно по
фондовому
и в этом плане я думаю мы Давайте
забегать вперёд не будем дальше по кругу
Я постараюсь строить дискуссию так
знаете слоями вот как углубляться
следующий У меня вопрос для всех ведёте
ли вы бюджет и Кто ведёт бюджет Если вы
семейная пара Ну у меня нет пары
спутника поэтому я веду сама и у меня
есть финансовый консультант
сестрёнка которая вот я она вообще в
этом деле Эксперт и я Она меня как-то
пригласила в жюри и там выступали
финансовые консультанты И мне очень
понравилось как один молодой человек Там
они за что-то боролись какой-то приз был
как он Расписал свой бюджет там условно
Он зарабатывает 200.000 тенге в месяц Да
там он мне понравилось я запомнил как он
на свою девушку выделяет ровно там
15.000 тенге там на проживание там ровно
70.000 тенге там транспорт и я
посмотрела на это и мне так понравилось
Я думаю я тоже так
хочу Ну в смысле Мне понравилось как он
прям щепетильно относится к сво де Не
разго имеете в виду он молодой там ему
1920 Студент Да и ну зарабатывает деньги
неплохие для студента там 200.000 я
подумала это классная система я решила
посчитать сколько я
трачу Это была плохая идея
мне было плохо я думаю ужас на что я
вообще трачу деньги я поняла что вот как
вы говорите экономия Да с другой стороны
Вы знаете я когда работала на
телевидении то есть наёмным
сотрудником максимум который я получала
там на хабаре Когда я была новости
работала корреспондентом 300.000 тенге
Угу курс был тогда другой курс был
другой Это был 201 там д по-моему год да
но в десятом году я уже открыла бизнес
вот до десятого года Скажем я ла там на
200 тире 300.000 тенге и я конечно жила
вот в рамках этой суммы Да но когда я
открыла бизнес Это был 2010 год Мы с
моей подругой Аида кауменова дизайнером
открыли а магазинчик небольшой там 50
квадратов Киру ене и у нас аренда была
630.000 тенге Ничего себе Да где-то в
среднем платье стоили 60.000 Я говорю
Аида короче 10 плать продаём мы
закрываем аренду потом ещё 10 платьев
продаём Мы в общем чего-то там
зарабатываем Если ещё 10 платьев продаём
мы мы пойдём в саду с тобой пить кофе
чай но пока мы не продадим 30 платьев Мы
отсюда не выйдем потому что у меня тогда
зарплата вообще была 200.000 и мы там
просто продавали Мы за 20 дней продали
всё что у нас было в магазине даже чужие
платили с выпили там получается у меня
не было сейфа дома Да я купила сейф
потому что я поняла что оказывается
бизнес - это классно но классно когда ты
готов отдать всю свою душу да там и при
этом я вела тогда новости мло что меня
узнают я там сама замеры снимала мне у
меня был такой знаете страх вот эти
630.000 тенге аренда и вот как бы затем
я начала очень хорошо зарабатывать Но я
всё равно экономи Как вы говорите да то
есть я всегда старалась там ну обходила
какие-то бренды Да понимала Зачем на это
тратить деньги но когда я начала себе
позволять Я начала зарабатывать ещё
больше потому что вот этот момент когда
ты начинаешь жить той жизнью
хотел бы Прити то ты тоже начинаешь
больше зарабатывать и когда у тебя есть
запрос и когда я взяла в рассрочку
квартиру у своей В общем у меня есть
дизайнерам Бира Вот у неё мамы
строительная компания и я живу как бы в
своей квартире пентхаусе я решила ну как
бы увеличить пространство и зачем-то я
пошла посмотреть их квартиру пентхаус
там 350 квадратов А я посмотрела и
подумала Да ну в рассрочку я могу
спокойненько там за 2 года
э тем боле тем
более я уже нормально зарабатываю
квартира же нуж она взяла
большую не
помещался в общем я поняла что нужно как
бы Вот деньги которые ты зарабатываешь
ежемесячно Куда ты инвестировать Да я
вот начала бы собирать И это тоже
классно потому когда
ты можешь их просто тратить бесконечно
да А тут у тебя уже появляется какой-то
инструмент Куда ты должен каждый месяц
там то есть у тебя бюджет есть просто
ведёт у тебя нет она мне вот открыла
глаза вот когда я сходила на эту встречу
на вот это вот я не знаю там был
какой-то конкурс это бы одноразово или
ты постоянно с После этого я начала
получать эти консультации А до этого Да
а до этого я честно говоря не не думала
что нужно вот так вот всё расписывать
понимаете
тех кто боится бюджетов потому что
бюджеты такой привкус бухгалтерии
бюрократии да Для тех кто боится
введения бюджета вот пожалуйста хороший
опыт Динары привлекайте специалиста либо
Найдите человека который Вам окажет эти
услуги по бюджетированию Сегодня мы
кстати ещё поговорим о простых системах
бюджетирования Ну хороший лайфхак вот
пожалуйста Хоть она и не сама ведёт но у
неё есть профессионал который ей
помогает а вот здесь вот кстати вот
вопрос я хотел тоже пока далеко от этой
тему не ушли вот есть качество женщины
когда она транжир есть качество женщины
когда она вот очень хорошо ведёт
бухгалтери вот говорят женщины хорошо
ведут бего то есть эти качества они не
противоречат друг другу а могут
уживаться в одной женщине А ну смотрите
когда вообще бухгалтер как профессия Это
женская профессия Это не вопрос не
сексизма а в том что женщины более
скрупулёзный более усидчивый более
внимательные чем мужчины и так далее
Поэтому вот бухгалтерия финансовая
аналитика - это всё-таки женские
профессии А И если
женщина занимается этим профессионально
то скорее всё у неё там всё в порядке
тоже с ведением поэтому это абсолютно не
противоречит они дополняет даже
Жас Кто у тебя ведёт бюджет и как вы
ведёте бюджет Да у меня бюджет В общем я
расскажу так то есть когда я начал
заниматься бизнесом То есть у меня
начали появляться средства и я начал
инвестировать их в разные бизнесы и один
из бизнесов который я открыл это было
такси То есть я купил тогда добера до
Яндек такси Я купил как раз таки вот
было новое такси которое работало именно
по программе то есть уже не было раций и
инвестировал около поя долларов То есть
мы дошли до того что у нас уже было в
парке около полтысячи машин причём это в
очень маленьком городе город стал да и
но она начала генерировать кэш То есть
это деньги пошли всё но я понял то что у
меня такая вот плохо качественная
женщина транжира сидит да И вот очень
много расходов То есть как бы не следил
за рас я понимал что вот сколько денег
приходило где-то иногда даже и больше
уходило и сейчас к пример я понял то что
вот так как у меня недостаточно качества
именно ведения правильного бюджета То
есть я это делегировал своей супруге То
есть у нас За семейным бюджетом следит
супруга А она кто по образованию она
финансист
она она Фин ра она нет она у меня прям
супер экономная супер у меня
тобой всё понятно То есть он поступил
так же как Динара тоже только на один
шаг круче он просто женился на финансист
Зачем платить зарплату Дима я как
наверное многие всегда начинал вести
доходы-расходы какую-нибудь Excel
табличку миллион программ А и всем
Рассказываю что это надо делать но как и
у большинства естественно ты всё
забываешь То есть тут вроде записал тут
вроде не записал и каждый раз ты
обнуляется вроде ну всё вот с этого года
надо начать вести чтобы было всё чётко у
меня здесь был хороший пример брата
потому что у моего брата есть статистика
затрат за все последние 10 лет вплоть до
того там Почём бензин заправлялся там 10
лет назад Да это наверное восхищает меня
в нём И то есть он по сей день ведёт но
у меня второй половинки нету мне некого
не на кого было скинуть Я не стал тут
решать вопрос
Давай поменяемся
Стара неплохая на другой по жена брата
она
возглавляла поскольку она возглавляла
все финансы нашей компании я как бы
понял что давай ты будешь вести как бы и
впредь как бы все свои затраты чтобы я
не забывал вести Я просто скидываю
WhatsApp человеку жене брата она всё это
фиксирует и каждый месяц я всегда могу
обратиться что происхо мо Фин где есть
где нет Прим у не есть право не давать
не выделять какие-то Деньги когда я хочу
куда-то вложить Она говорит нет Сейчас
нет свободных денег как бы приходить
Через 2 месяца то есть вот она меня так
скажем финансово здесь сдерживает как бы
причём Мы очень часто можем ругаться там
но я понимаю что это как раз тот человек
Кто помогает мне держать что Деги
быть внимание с э
при этом бюджеты у него ведёт тоже
другой человек отдельный человек более
того вот э хорошая вещь это часто Мы
применяем в инвестициях когда знаете
проблема в инвестициях ещё часто бывает
как когда ты не учитывает свой
темперамент если брать Вот я сангвиник
например да А я у меня был партнёр Эрик
Найман очень крутой эксперт по трейдингу
он автор лучших бестселлеров книг в СНГ
и так далее мы с ним до сих пор хорошо
общаемся кстати КПЕ Он будет вести один
блок так вот у нас были такие условия
что я определяю куда инвестировать а он
определяет сколько
инвестировать таким образом
риск-менеджмент если я слишком
оптимистично подхожу говорю блин Давай
сюда вставим там ну не буду озвучивать
цифру лько а он понимает что не согласен
с этим он моё решение отменить не может
но он говорит Хорошо Ну тогда такая-то
сумма и минимизирует ошибки мои и это
очень классно ратат особенно в
инвестициях Возьмите этот лайфхак для
инвестиции Если вы чрезмерно
оптимистичный человек то у вас огромная
вероятность
соверши Поэтому лучше всего Чтобы рядом
был
реалист А лучше всего флегматик вот я
больше по ЕС это брокер например
брокер смотрите он всегда на стороне
того чтобы вы больше торговали то есть
потому что он зарабатывает
комисси надо смотреть на ЧМ он зает
больше продавать Покупать больше
продавать покупать он не заинтересован
Ну будем так говорить частично
заинтересован чтобы вы зарабатывали и а
не так чтобы для него не выгодно чтобы
вы купили один раз и сидели там 10-15
лет Нурлан Кто у вас ведёт бюджет Ну
если я владелец компании кинокомпании
кастле продукт и у нас есть финансовый
директор бухгалтерия если по компании
это по компании понятно там Финанс дирек
хорошо мы сейчас говорим личные Финанс Я
всё-таки хочу тиш месяц больше вывести
на налёт его больше компании Понятно А
дома э жена доверяет мне а поэтому А я
не доверяю А ты делал ей В смысле выбор
давал ей предложение жена доверяет мне а
я не доверяю никому даже себе Да да да
Ну расскажу один момент э я снимал
первый фильм денег не хватало как-то
что-то не получилось Я мне пришлось
сдать э подволок свою квартиру Остане
здесь машину зала и всё притык но фильм
когда снимаешь но ещё ждёшь год пока он
отобью программы я там должен хорошо
выглядеть костюмы Аша ноль денег нет но
всё на улице люди фотографируются в
образе ты думаешь блин 10.000 теге
реально был такой момент что жена
говорит надо вечером Гости придут надо
что-то купить чтобы дела А у нас жена
знает и мне что мне нравится Ари она не
переживает ЕС СШ не переживаешь
будет только в феврале вот будет будет и
какой-то момент дочка приносит копилку
она услышала что у нас денег нет и она
даёт пап У нас есть
деньги 30
ми зна что де перед миллиардом
что какой-то месяц есть Ну обратно
что-то будет феврале где-то марте но
данный момент было тяжело и дочка так
говорит и чуть поплакали и с этого
момента я решил уже думать имеется в
виду как раньше там кв всё там я вот та
у меня такая что же теория была я если
буду больше зарабатывать где-то что-то
минусы но всё равно останется не
переживать тогда ещё не было там
помощников или там финансовых директор
вот такс
деньги вы
потратили дочки Да потратили но вернули
а вернули Да да мы до сих пор вспоминаем
ты молодец очень Вот ещё один хороший
лайфхак Если Вам трудно и не хватает
денег пройдитесь по сусекам своих детей
там я на самом деле это шутка но с
другой стороны я вспоминаю себя Я с
детства любил копить деньги и самое
интересное я не относился к деньгам как
средство потребления и одно время я
накопил в чулке я хранил вот такой
Длинный чулок я 270 руб по тем временам
у меня мать зарабатывала 110 отец 140
ну две зарплаты Да оба зарабатывали
зарабатывали вместе 250 А у меня было
270 ге всё в копейках всё в копейках Я в
начале покупал такие для того чтобы
монеты собирать это всё закончилось И в
чулке в конце начал собирать и здесь
вопрос касательно воспитания детей если
дети ваши коллекционируют или собирают
деньги только поощряйте поощряйте потому
что это создаёт важный психологический
навык
а умение терпеть не покупать то что
сейчас хочется угу а а вот есть
Исследование по-моему гарвардской
Исследование где Они проводили
исследование в отношении детей это было
самом Одно из самых Долгих исследований
э и ставили конфетки перед детьми
выходили и Кто кушал в конце выяснилось
те дети которые терпели и и
дожидались воспитателя не кушали конфету
они в жизни добивались больших успехов
то есть терпение и успех в жизни Они
напрямую коррелируют и вот из истории
Нурлана хотел бы про иллюстрировать
такую вещь а есть одно такое заблуждение
что оно красивое правда заблуждение я
сам тоже часто это привожу достаточно Не
бойтесь больших расходов бойтесь
маленьких доходов Угу А и В этом плане
звучит красиво что надо всё внимание
обращать на доходы но я здесь сегодня
именно хочу сделать акцент что важно
акцент на управление деньгами важно не
размер доходов и не размер расходов а
важно умение управлять деньгами то есть
вот это очень важно потому что лю этому
нужно учиться да да потому что многие
люди наращивают доходы всё равно не
справляются с расходами потому что
расходы аппетит вместе с этими растут а
самая плохая психологическая Ловушка
которая у нас есть у каждого
человека наш мозг не понимает
отсроченный платёж то есть вот когда он
сказал что доходы придут через год но
ментально он уже их оприходовал
ментально он вёл себя уже как будто они
у него в кармане но и это ошибка
большинства людей люди будущие доходы
считают что они уже у него в кармане и
начинают их тратить и поэтому вят в
кредиты и часто берут под будущую
зарплату под будущее там это типа у меня
же есть ему зарплату только повысили а
он уже берёт кредит понимая что о у него
же доходы вырос даже вот в Голливуде же
очень много историй когда там актёры
зарабатывали огромные деньги но просто
потому что они Не умели управлять
деньгами они всё потеряли ты просто
супер пример привела Мы же все
удивляемся как в нищете умерли вот эти
знаменитости куча знаменитостей причём
вплоть до Майкла Дже
Мак тан сейчас например да сколько
зарабатывал Милн 50 100 Милн сейчас типа
вот вот этот ещё раз показывает что
управление деньгами важнее чем доходы и
расходы А где этому
учиться на самом
деле Просто я число хочу уть
кот ионный Там чисто подготовка
инвестора это по
Фин я буду делать отдельный курс но
вообще в интернете везде хватает и в
этом плане я нет может быть вы дадите
какую-то рекомендацию у кого именно
обучиться этому ой Честно говоря я сам
не смотрю никого из других Почему Потому
что я во-первых а времени нет Я даже
интервью не успеваю там которые мне
присылают важный просмотреть времени
во-вторых я боюсь что на меня не
повлияло потому что у меня своё
мировозрение своё понимание и так далее
а я сам готовлю курс в этом году будет
курс Личные финансы финансы для бизнеса
финансы для инвесторов Когда будет ну Ой
это такой на больную мозоль мне даешь у
меня там целая просто срочно нужно
срочно срочно что все деньги потра та
вопросы Я же просто ну как не не
бизнесмен творческий человек хочу
снимать фильм в Африке можно снять там
за малую сумму в Алмате потому что мы
здесь всех знаем всё понятно цены
Понятно Октал там пальмы есть да Октал
пальмы есть это и но хочется снять в
Африке чтобы зритель увидел на экране
что-то другое там казахи встретится
африканца или казахи встретится с
американцами но она дороже вот как Вы
сказали что мы могли бы и не вернуть эти
деньги но вот это прямо желание показать
какое-то качество но всё-таки в конце
это лучше стало потому что мы как-то
кассовый сбор какой-то Обновили Лан
Почему вы говорите что вы не бизнесмен У
вас же бизнес по казахски в пяти странах
мира международный сетевой бизнес с
налогой сидят
[смех]
меро просто чтобы шутка удалась я с
налого сказал я знаю Нет ну как раз Дима
же эксперт по скрытия
налогов по оптимизации Ну а здесь что
порекомендовать относительно того что
вот пойти на этот путь так скажем как-то
менять мышление своё и отношение к
деньгам однозначно Я бы рекомендовал
начать с книги самый богатый человек в
Вавилоне это вот ну основа Я рекомендую
детям взрослым всем Потому что вот как
раз таки почитав эту книгу у большинства
закладывается хотя бы желание что-то
менять в своих финансах Потому что если
это работало так много лет назад а все
истины на поверхности лежат Ты читаешь и
хочешь начать что-то менять кстати сходу
вспомнил есть же хорошая книга Роберта
кисаки Богатый папа бедный папа Да и не
знаю какая из них но там у него есть
раскладка по доходам расходам активам
пассивам Вот это кстати ещё одна очень
важная часть Но вообще конечно лучше
наверное вот чтобы вы запустили такую
курс потому что вы знаете нашу
ментальность у нас же помимо того что у
нас
есть доходы расходы у нас есть ещё а
реалии там у нас же есть очень много
тоев да там у нас много родственников Да
которым мы тоже помогаем Да помимо
благотворительности есть и асы то есть И
вот просто например Я недавно начала
играть в чёрную кассу
и это вообще такая тема с юга Да я всё
время слышала её но мне было всегда
интересно да как это вот играть в чёрную
кассу и вот в прошлом году мы с
девчонками собрались с подругами и
что-то вот как-то Вот разговор зашёл Я
говорю давайте поиграем вот я реально
столько слышал мне интересно ну так как
все мои подружки предпринимательницы мы
такие сначала Давайте по 500.000 у нас
10 человек типа сразу человек получает 5
млн А потом когда мы начали играть уже
вот когда пришли мы говорим что по 5500
Давайте по миллиону 10 Милонов за раз и
я была как раз
первая Давайте
по Нет по мил это на самом деле этоже
как кредит Да но мы договорились с
девочками что эти деньги мы будем
тратить на что-то Ну не просто вот
получилось 10 млн и растра А что это
либо квартира либо машина и вот я купила
машину Ну смысле деньги и купила машину
Угу стирали Маши Ну
конечно нет я просто к тому что рядом с
сейфом поставить что это тоже какой-то
мне кажется давайте как раз вот ты
сказала про чёрную кацу ч
катере не про чёрную кацу Давайте
обсудим актуальную проблему для нашей
аудитории это финансовые пирамиды А дело
в том что реа ЧР Кас это финансова мед
нет нет меня натолкнуло натолкнуло на на
эту мысль поговорить о финансовых
пирамидах потому что реально это такая
большая боль на ней попадает очень много
по данным агентства по филь надзору в
прошлом году по-моему казахстанцы около
30 млрд тенге потратили на финансовые
пирамиды А вернее не потратили а
потеряли на финансовых пирамидах Я в
прошлом году сам запарился бороться с
этими рекламами мой юрист зафиксировал
рекорд Мы в июне прошлого года закрыли
308 рекламных ресурсов с моим
изображением о том что я там рекламирую
финансовый пирамиды я посты писал и так
далее не работаю ещё юристы все ссылки я
туда отправлял и статистика У нас есть
он говорит 308 в месяц Да закрыли
рекламных этих То есть это какой-то бич
на самом деле и я понимаю что это
проблема не тех кто создаёт даже а в том
что есть спрос есть спрос на финансовые
пирамиды соответственно Ну люди и ведут
А почему есть спрос Ну потому что там
процент очень высокий И люди
расскажем был ли у кого-то из нас опыт
опыт это знаете как как это был ли у вас
сексуальный О
давай мы держим деньги финансовых
пирамид хороший процент Расскажи
расскажи истори помимо чёрной кассы это
мы поняли чя ка в жизни ты сталкивался с
финансовыми пирамидами и А есть же ещё
ну не финансова пирамида Я знаю женщины
очень патки на м на
продажи вот
эти Нет
этис эти Коти Ну вы смотрите
Я не знаю Надеюсь что это всё-таки не
финансовая пирамида Я в прошлом году
инвестировала в криптовалюту и на это
меня какой из них биткойн это был Март
прошлого года потому что меня пригласили
ведущие на это мероприятие Я приехала но
когда я увидела сколько Люде верят Да в
криптовалюту и что На вот этом трейдинге
да зарабатывают и там вот собрались
именно те кто в этой системе да то есть
они работают амбассадоры они как
называют друг друга Они там дарили такие
подарки
клифы поса я просто когда это всё
посмотрела я поняла что я вообще отстала
от жизни и вообще почему я этим не
занимаюсь да то есть нуно я естественно
не стала амбассадором Потому что я боюсь
Это рекламировать ну это большая
ответственность но я конечно
проинвестировать именно в этот день
почему-то биткойн начал
падать вот с тех пор когда он был 59.000
вот и он начал вот так вот падать падать
ты по 59 вошла прямо на пике на пике
классика вот с подружкой я вот это
обсуждала и она говорит Ты знаешь ди
конь у нас всё-таки мы с тобой этот
крестьяне солнце встало пошли в поле То
есть у нас не работает что когда ты
вложил потому что мне каждый второй
подходил и говорил
ное А вот мы рабле потрите мы правильно
инвестировали я посмотрела на людей
думаю действительно Я в общем
инвестировала в одну компанию во вторую
компанию я эти деньги не трогаю они там
так и лежат Я всё-таки верю что
когда-нибудь эта криптовалюта вырастет в
цене но у меня был случай когда была
компания как же называ
девчонки зашли и они вот как раз обещали
там бешеные проценты 20 по-моему 30% я
видела как людям раздают эти деньги но я
послушав всех поняла что это уже конец
потому что ну там прям очень много было
денег Я Слава Богу туда не зашла поэтому
я не теряла денег Но ты не зашла из
одного соображения что это был конец Ну
я просто как знаете журналист Я просто
всех послушала подавала вопросы и я
поняла что это уже долгая какая-то
история Я же знаю что финансовые
пирамиды Они то есть там в начале ещё ты
можешь какую-то что-то там получается
Если бы это было начало ты могла клюнуть
Ну наверное нет Потому что я в биткойн
только вообще о криптовалюте Я только в
прошлом году узнала и я я думала что это
всё-таки больше вот мне казалось что это
финансовые пирамиды но затем изучив я
вот сейчас вот изучаем ту вселенную Я
всё-таки думаю что у криптовалюты есть
будущее утя я Вот и понимаю что они ни к
чему не прикреплены акции прикреплены Да
хотя там тоже сколько там не знаю
триллионов акций Да там У Теслы говорят
эти деньги там через 400 лет Да только
вернутся тоже как-то вот Странно вроде
бы но вот в это и в это веришь и в это
но
в финика я не вступала то есть фн
хоя те негативного опыта нетти
есть опыт когда я проинвестировать и он
начал падать я даже не знаю сколько он
сейчас стоит Я просто перестала туда
смотреть я поняла что когда-нибудь мне
сказали он вырастет я в это верю это
наша классическая психология А когда
любой актив который ты покупаешь обычно
всегда так особенно новички Когда
покупаешь любой актив он сразу же
начинает падать Вот именно в момен
Почему именно от меня это это у всех
имен именно каждый начинающий инвестор
начинает думать именно почему это у меня
почему это произошло со мной это первое
потом падает потом инвестор думает Блин
назад Вот отрастёт продам он не
отрастает дальше падает и ивер думает
Блин что я тогда не продал надо будет
вот сейчас хотя бы до этого уровня
отрастёт продам он дальше падает и в
какой-то момент инвестор говорит всё
Теперь я буду сидеть до конца ты сейчас
находишься в стадии до
конца у тебя поздравляем тея
это
опыт у тебя был опыт с финансовыми
пирамидами Ну к счастью
э я ну то есть встречал очень много на
своём пути пирамид и предложений войти в
разные пирамиды но к счастью То есть я
не вступал ни в какую пирамиду потому
что вот наверное из-за того что рано
начал как бы заниматься бизнесом то есть
и я понимал что лучше Вот Если деньги
есть вложить в бизнес как-то его развить
нежели то есть давать в ту пирамиду то
есть ну в непонятную организацию где ты
вкладываешь деньги и ничего не получаешь
Угу и я ну на данный момент я понимаю
что то есть это вот как Вы сказали бич
нашего общества потому что то есть
большинство людей идут туда из-за как
раз таки отсутствия финансовой
грамотности то есть и это желание быстро
заработать получить лёгкие деньги отсюда
же идёт и вот букмекерские конторы
всякие лато пирамиды ставки Да и очень
большое количество людей то есть это вот
по статистике говорят у нас там сотни
тысяч людей то есть занимаются вот этим
и там долгий долг их там десятки у
каждого то есть там десятки миллионов
тенге из-за этого распадаются семьи да
то есть это приводит это очень большая
такая проблема нашего общества да И как
раз-таки это вот упирается вот
финансовую грамотность а которую нужно
поднимать даже вот сейчас государство
говорит о том то есть постоянно
поднимать благосостояние народа Но это
государство говорит с высоких трибун но
здесь важно понимать что слышит простое
население что слышит народ и большинство
весь народ он слышит Вот сейчас деньги
полетят вертолётные деньги как все
говорят да то есть как бы и сейчас мы
начнём тратить да и это то есть они все
ждут рыбу почему то есть как бы ну если
вот копнуть прям очень глубоко да то
есть это всё уходит в детство то есть
потому что вот было такое воспитание
потому что то есть не научили
зарабатывать не научили терпеть не не
дали То есть как бы не заложили те Вот
именно финансовые основы которые то есть
привели бы в это в будущем да То есть
как бы вот люди которые этим занимаются
они вот приходят к тем результатам
который то есть мы сейчас имеем а для
того чтобы вот мы сейчас даже вот я
Почему хотел Ну вот этот момент затронул
а сейчас вот у нас в государстве приняли
концепцию повышения финансовой
грамотности там 20-24 Да я её смотрел но
там начинается вот
школа потом колледжи университет то и
дальше Угу но нету детского сада Угу и
вот есть были очень такие вот известные
есть исследования где вот лауреат
Нобелевской премии То есть он получил
свою премию за то что он доказал что не
когнитивные навыки то есть они больше
влияют на успех Угу И не имеет смысл их
развивать после пяти лет Угу Когда мы
встречались то есть с Министерством
образования Мы говорили о том что мы
занимаемся внедрением инноваций в сфере
образования что надо детей до 5 лет то
есть обучать потому что то есть в этом
закладывается основа то есть основа
всего да личности а дальше то есть уже
нет и получается школа она каждый год
получает Ну если так можно выразиться
недо инновационных детей то есть в Ну в
школе да то есть и каждый год с ними
работает А если бы мы обратили внимание
сда то есть потому что здесь вот даже
тоже вот ещё другие вот три лауреата
Нобелевской прения делали исследования И
говорили о том
что то есть они пришли к тому что
большинство всех вот
глобальных глобальных программ и
национальных программ по Иско бедности
то есть они не работают должным образом
потому что они создаются Вот именно в
высоких кабинетах А на местах То есть
как бы они не работают Почему Потому что
то есть там совсем другой уровень
проблем и они спустились прям до каждой
прям до конкретной семьи поняли ЧМ у них
проблема то есть они даже вот решали
такую проблему Как
повысить успеваемость в школе и они
пришли к тому что даже вот Элементарные
недорогие медицинской уход То есть он
повышает успеваемость потому что к
примеру у детей есть такая проблема там
как паразиты да И эти паразиты они не
дают детям заниматься должным образом то
есть они постоянно велят в школу не
ходит пропускают их беспокоит постоянно
организм и простая вакцина 3,5 доллара в
год решает эту проблему намного лучше
чем те самые многомиллионные программы
по мотивации то есть детей к обучению
Угу И мы должны Ну мне как кажется то
есть понимать именно вот эту проблему То
есть как народ понимает то есть для того
чтобы в целом если даже сейчас Пойдёт то
есть опять же то есть самое главное То
есть это создание рабочих мест для того
чтобы у людей появился заработок для
того чтобы они смогли сформировать свою
Дельту и в дальнейшем то есть уже её
грамотно использовать то есть не
какие-либо пирамиды там непонятные там
инструменты да то есть привлечения
сейчас которых очень много а вот именно
в правильном направлении Дима твой опыт
И почему ты думаешь люди идут в
финансовые пирамид кстати
хорошую именно тему расширил в плане
того что Давайте поговорим Почему люди
туда идут и на самом деле у нас в жизни
смотрите пирамиды букмекерские конторы
казино это на самом деле скачки вот эти
это это всё пирамиды на самом деле Ну не
не пирамиды А если брать психологическую
основу то это желание заработать всё и
сразу много и сразу Ну вот и прошу
прощения я Дим ещё хотел момент просто
пока не забыл вот я считаю Вот как раз
вот это вот можно решить только через
обучение финансовой грамотности но до
обучения финансовой грамотности Я считаю
что нужно делать воспитание финансовой
грамотности как раз таки вот маленьких
детей то есть вот начиная с детского
возраста чтобы они сначала вот научились
себя вести то есть упорству да то есть
тем качествам которые приведут к то и в
дальнейшем то есть уже только давать
именно эти обучающие инструменты я
просто думаю тоже пока Э
тема финансовая грамотность мы их
обучаем если него за 000 тенге хоть он
мощно финансово грамотны он дете асом
деньги туда сюда дет э в нашей стране
думаю условий не хватает зарабатывать
денег например в разных странах есть и
скачки и ставки вот эти пирамиды разные
и в Америке и в Лондоне есть просто
какой количество процент населения
участвует в этом Потому что я знаю очень
много знакомых которые у них зарплата
60-80 000 тенге у них просто канча
грамотной восо да у них вариантов нету в
ауле население мелкое там что-то что-то
уже забито такси забито базар забиты что
ему делать поэтому мы просто чуть-чуть
затронули
государство что надо надо создавать
условия чтобы человеку Дать шанс на
заработать честным
путём создавать эту Атмосфера просто
здесь проблема заключается в том то что
человек который идёт в финансовую
пирамиду он думает что он идёт
инвестировать деньги что он думает что
согласен что есть неграмотность
финансовая да
согласен Мы же сами же там смотрим О
кто-то попал плачет там мы думали
заработаем на самом деле я сам не
попадая в пирамиды но ко мне обращаются
ежедневно там десятки людей Кто попадает
в Пирамиды во все мошеннические схемы и
здесь не соглашусь относительно того что
люди отчасти рассматривают это как
инвестиции и это проблема финансовой
безграмотности Да оно у нас есть
финансовая неграмотность но в половине
случаев Человек идёт в пирамиду зная что
это пирамида
то есть здесь больше вопрос что нас всех
не научили мыслить Так что там надо
ставить свои планы на 10-20 лет
откладывать собирать идти не спеша так
как у нас ситуация у людей нет
накопления у людей там ну скопил он свою
1000 долларов за 3 года у него есть
надежда что вот вдруг я в начале
пирамиды и у дво свои деньги за какой-то
месяц два-три и они идут на риск Ну они
идут по сути в казино Да потому что я
знаю очень много людей кто квартиру
продаёт или с т кредит миды идут берут
кредит и инвестируют для того чтобы Кто
хочет играть в азартные игры он будет
играть имеется в виду надо просто в
обществе уменьшать этот процен таже Я
думаю потому что и в Англии и в Китае и
в Америке в Австралии есть люди которые
официально ставят там на футбол там
здесь надо просто понимать чем беднее мы
все живём тем больше будет таких схем
где мы будем терять деньги здесь
надеяться на какие-то программы вот к
примеру государство Я тоже читал на 2024
год Ну на самом деле чем народ
образованнее тем тяжелее удержать многие
места свои и в правительстве и везде
поэтому сказать все по всему
постсоветском пространству я не согласен
что там какому-то государству выгодно
повышать финансовую грамотность
населения То есть тут Наверное каждый
просто сам должен до этого дойти что не
ждать помощи от государства не ждать
какие-то вертолётные деньги всё что пока
ты сам не возьмёшь это в руки и не
начнёшь сам погружаться а лучше
погружать своих детей в первую очередь
потому что многим уже поздно это изучать
что ничего не изменится ты не на
собираешь не накопишь каже как вы начали
же рано работать у меня просто сын тоже
с 9 лет занимается бизнесом он в
двадцатом году когда вот помните только
пандемия началась он продавал маски
где-то с февраля и там в марте он
продаёт тюльпаны то есть чем раньше
начинает человек заниматься бизнесом и
тогда он понимает что действительно там
каждый теньге Да ты можешь заработать
просто благодаря своим
усилиям может быть культивировать именно
Как евреи Да они же так воспитывают
своих
детей Ой извиняюсь есть ученики выдают
курсы Мне нравится да я тоже наблюдаю в
Инстаграме Мне тоже тоже охота
записаться тоже финансово грамотность
улучшить таким образом вы человек
[музыка]
молодым бизнесменам они другим помогут
так мне кажется это правильная стратегия
и учить несмотря на государство Мы
всегда жм от
государства они дож быть Финан это надо
культивировать потому что один пример Мы
всегда ждали у государства когда
государство нам для фильма кино деньги
даст но
отото ки фильмы сам вложил и люди
увидели что это как сказать рентабельно
не то что фильме они хотят заработать
просто можно по-другому какой-то пример
пошёл И последнее до пандемии в
Казахстане где-то
4550 частные компании снимали фильмы это
очень много Да это очень ного Это я к
тому что не то что хвалю свою индустрию
то что это один из примеров что когда
человек не ждёт государства А можно
самому вкладывать А как это деньги
вернуть надо качественно снимать чтобы
в экраны и зритель у зрителя должно
появиться квотам доверия этому продукту
казахстанскому кино это получается целая
индустрия и вот это всё
культивирует да да здесь смотрите если
говорить в целом по финансовы пирамидам
это такой процесс достаточно сложный и
говорит что первое что после него сложно
это как дилемма курицы и яйца но в тоже
время ясе
понятные что всё идёт с детства если
вкратце
подытожить Да наверное всё идёт с
детства но я бы сказал даже не с детства
всё начинается с идеологии Проблема в
том что мы в Казахстане если брать
структуру экономики то у нас 60%
занимается самру Казна 25-27 занимает
казахмыс Евразийская плюс тенги шевро
плюс остальные крупные у нас в
Казахстане частного бизнеса всего 13-15
ВВП экономики и получается так что мы Мы
везде декларируя и в законах у нас
прописано что мы строим капитализм а на
самом деле мы живём при
социализме любое увеличение доли
государства в экономике обязательно
ведёт к росту эдвенче настроений любое
увеличение доли государства Потому что
когда государство во всех секторах
начинает доминировать свободному
бизнесмену не хочется конкурировать
потому что там оно выстраивает
несправедливые условия у государства
всегда ресурсы дешёвые копеечные и они
бездарно за взятки раздают
соответственно частный бизнес не ходит
Не хочет На том поле работать
соответственно А все остальные давай
давай давай нам подачки повысить пенсии
зарплаты повысить и так далее и так
далее соответственно О какой финансовой
грамотности можно говорить особенно в
отношении детей когда дети Особенно ты
вот говоришь младший возраст до 5 лет
Они в это время не понимают язык в это
время они понимают только одно это
обучение на примере и если их родители
тянут от зарплаты до зарплаты ели концы
с концами сводят то о какой финансовой
грамотности детей можно говорить они не
могут обучать
детей то что сами ничего не достигли
дети Они они умные они на примерах
учатся поэтому Э тема на самом деле
обширная и большая Это вопрос идеологии
Это вопрос воспитания это вопрос
образования Ну и это вопрос структуры
самой экономики мы сейчас можем поменять
даже идеологию Но если будем продолжать
себя вести в экономике государство будет
продолжать се также то ничего не
изменится а Поэтому я считаю что вот то
что токаев сейчас сказал что сократить
долю государства в экономики это окажет
больший эффект как раз как те 3 с по
долларовые эти когда государство уходит
с экономики Начинает появляться очень
много частного бизнеса А много частного
бизнеса это это движняк это успешные
родители это соответственно обучение
детей больше детей вовлекается в
экономический оборот и так далее и так
далее а это если говорить Э мы сейчас о
финансовых пирамидах и я понял что на
самом деле мы сейчас говорили не только
о финансовых пирамидах А вообще о
психологии наших людей
э которые хотят всё быстро и очень много
э теперь то что касается Нурлан Ремарка
ты прав что во всех странах есть это Но
во всех странах это есть для людей
обеспеченных для тех кто жиру бесится
пойти в казино просрать 10 млн долларов
не вопрос Если у тебя 100 млн есть Ну
иди прос 10 млн не вопрос Ты хочешь
пойти ставки по миллион долларов ста не
вопрос Если у тебя доходы 10 млн
долларов в год ставь Ставки Не вопрос в
этом беды нету Беда в том что когда этим
начинают играть люди на последнее Это
первый момент а второе очень плохо когда
они думают что они инвестируют а
не делают азартные ставки и вот здесь
Я плавно подхожу к теме ошибки Дело в
том что существует два типа ошибок один
тип ошибок - это ошибки понимания второй
тип ошибок ошибки поведения и вот ошибки
понимания когда люди думают что они
инвестируют вот это большая проблема
когда они покупают машину и думают что
инвестируют вот это большая проблема на
самом деле они не инвестируют они
создают будущие проблемы Я приведу
пример один разн
и купил зажигалку з золотую
и катером ну катер который режет сигары
на стол положил Я говорю О крутая
зажигалка крутой катер говорю блин
говорю на пять штук Попал ты он говорит
Да не какой п штук 600 долларов я гово
за 600 долларов купил я говорю да это
600 долларов Смотри ты же прил же не в
кармане держал же прил на тво
Сидим с друзьями это твой жиз значит что
ты это купил для того чтобы вот так на
стол брякнуть перед друзьями Ну то есть
похвастаться так вот ты же для этого
купил так Ну теперь ты это купил ты же
не можешь не курить сигару это есть а
сигары нет Но это же глупость
соответственно у тебя Ты должен купить
сигару так так хорошо вот и он достаёт
сигару Ну я говорю Смотрю сигара Ромео
джульет Дорогая давидов у тебя я говорю
этих гаров в Казахстане Нет ты
заказываешь в Америке каждая сигара там
150-1 баксов это дорого так Так ты же не
можешь дешёвые дешманские сигары курить
и вот это резать Это же вообще капец же
да тем более все друзья же
разбираются соответственно ты берёшь
обязательно купишь дорогую сигару Ага
хорошо дальше Ты когда купишь дорогую
сигару Ты же при нас не можешь сигару
просто курить сухомятку Ты же
обязательно вискарик купишь потому что
сигаре вискарик либо коньячок Так ведь
соответственно Вот ты будешь попадать на
вискарик и коньячок дальше сигары ты так
как заказываешь с Америки Ты же не
поштучно заказываешь а сразу много
значит нужно хранить сигары для этого
хуми дор а хуми дор стоит пожалуйста три
штуки бакса самый дешёвый потому что
ящик для сигар который поддерживает
влажность температуру и так далее и так
далее А вот у тебя получается и ты
попадаешь на хуми дор и вот когда я
посчитал там У меня вышло 55 6.000
долларов он вот так попал Я говорю
смотрите психология бедных людей они
покупают вот такую зажигалку и думают
что всё Это зажигалка на самом деле это
стоит 500 там или 600 долларов на самом
деле это является триггером того что ты
попадёшь на шесть штук Вот это это
всегда вот нужно учитывать Кстати я это
называю цена владения этого термина
нигде нет я сам вывел цена владения А в
моём понимании это когда ты любую вещь
берёшь и у тебя эта вещь за собой тащит
целый шлейф дополнительных расходов
любую вещ ве это дорогое обслуживание Да
однозначно дорогие дорогое обслуживание
это дорогие покрышки зимние ты же не
можешь смол мо фильм Холодное сердце и
пошли игрушки Да пошли игрушки Ну там ну
игрушки это ещё не обязательный атрибут
это знаешь будет когда ты на Холодное
сердце повёл ребёнка Угу а потом потому
что если ты сам посмотрел ты не попадёшь
на это да ты игрушки А если ты повёл
ребёнка то ты попадёшь на это потому что
ребёнок скажет Папа купи это Купи это
Купи это так далее Поэтому вот это
ошибки распространённые ошибки
управления финансами инвестирования и
так далее вот я хотел бы вот Поделитесь
вы какие вы видите ошибки у людей в
части управления финансами
инвестиции У меня даже больше не ошибки
я вот просто смотрю в Москве на блогеров
Да и так как я сама журналист и плавно
текла моя профессия блогерство Да я
смотрю на них я хожу там на различные
тусовки я вижу что они все ездят на
Lamborghini Да майба при этом вот я Так
примерно понимаю Да сколько они
зарабатывают у нас вчера вот тоже
блогеры из Астаны купили себе
rolls-royce я Занимаюсь бизнесом Да я
Хорошо зарабатываю но я не могу себе
позволить купить rolls-royce Я вот думаю
это ради хайпа то есть то есть они так
делают Да надо по или же это вот как вы
говорите да то есть когда там потому что
я как-то разговаривала со своим другом
беби тамм Але беком Да он там на бенли
катается с 20 лет и меня бе вотт как-то
один раз просто так оборони такую фразу
что ты знаешь сколько мне дверей открыл
этот Bentley то есть иногда это вот эта
вот цена владения Как вы говорите да то
есть ты покупаешь какую-то вещь которая
может быть ещё больше внимания и ещё
больше доходов тебе приносит Ну вот ты
хорошо сказала де потому что вот то что
касается инфобизнесменов Да а для них
это не есть
ы объект потребление это объект доходов
То есть это всё равно что вложить в
рекламу Они же вкладывают в рекламу и
благодаря этому Bentley они говорят
смотрите вот я
а купил бенли благодаря своим знаниям
соответственно Вот вы купите у меня мои
курсы и тогда вы тоже купите это по сути
всё равно что купить Ну ре позволяю Я
живу потому что ты не продаёшь курсы о
том как заработать на Бент Нет нет я
понимаю что это тоже может быть там как
реклама бы выглядело Да но я всё-таки
люблю жить соответственно своим доходом
да то есть я например допустим январь -
это такой не самый лучший месяц для
бизнеса Да поэтому сегодня Я прилетела в
остано ой в алмаату экономо понимаете То
есть я если хорошо зарабатывают То есть
я прилечу бизнесом поэтому я
стараюсь могу взять и пить себе тоже да
но я понимаю что во-первых это дорого Да
во-вторых ну я не живу так чтобы
кататься на роллс-ройсе То есть ты
считаешь что нужно чётко расходы строить
под свои доходы Мне кажется нужно быть
Вот в этом смысле реалистом да то есть и
жить вот позволяет мне мой заработок вот
особенно сейчас Да вот когда вот
произошли вот эти январские события я
задумалась что Да у меня есть активы но
Если бы там условно алмаату захватили
там Астану к примеру захватили Да там и
мы остались бы там условно без власти
и может быть там экономика бы да встала
то что бы я бы делала да например то
есть Я же не могу срочно продать свою
машину да то есть её никто не купит
квартиру никто не купит да то есть
бизнес он просто закроется и всё станет
как пандемию я впервые в жизни увидела
как торговый центр мы на Новый год даже
никогда на 31 декабря не закрывались всё
закрылось Я просто представил что я
должна делать да то есть там пошла в
банк мне говорят Вы можете 100.000
только тенге Да снять и в такие моменты
ты понимая что очень важно м Иметь Иметь
наличку наличку в
сейфе Да иметь наличку иметь вообще
какой-то ну я не знаю Капитал или вот я
не знаю там акции да что-то Что поможет
тебе вот там условно семью взять уехать
куда-то и что-то такое у тебя должно
быть для того чтобы ты в такой таких
форс-мажорных обстоятельствах по же в
виртуальном мире да да ну в виртуальном
мире я не знаю но что-то что у тебя
где-то там я не знаю хранится Да и ты
можешь позволить себе куда-то уехать и
там пожить какое-то время не работая Да
потому что мы же Привыкли что мы
работаем мы молоды мы здоровы мы можем
заработать всегда Мы верим что в
следующем месяце мы заработаем Да свои
деньги А в такие моменты понимаешь что
ты вообще тебе не принадлежишь вот
друзья как раз Динара хорош
подняла вопрос Это один из лайфхаков
тоже можете себе отметить А дело в том
что когда мы говорим об инвестиционной
декларации и когда мы
рассматриваем портфель инвестора и чему
Мы обучаем мы обязательно смотрим такой
пункт А есть ли у человека финансовая
подушка Потому что если у человека нету
финансовой подушки то он никогда не
будет успешным инвестициях это наличие
финансовой подушки важно не только в
вашей повседневной жизни Но это важно и
для инвестирования потому что финансовая
подушка очень сильно влияет на то как вы
воспринимаете флуктуации цен то есть на
вашу психологию очень сильно Если Вы на
последнем это знаете есть закон подлости
если ты играешь на последнем то ты
Огромно вероятность что ты потеряешь Нет
у меня есть были деньги на карточках Да
но я просто поняла что я пришла говорю в
банк и мне говорят Вы можете снять
100000 тенге Ну то есть тебя
ограничивают Да даже банки тебе говорят
Извини помните там не работал да то есть
ты всё равно у тебя какие-то ограничения
стоят поэтому
М не знаю вот я поняла что вот как бы
сумочки туфли и прочее это конечно
хорошо и там я планировала ещё много
магазинов открыть А сейчас я поняла что
нет всё-таки нужно очень прям
распределить чётко свои яйца в разные
корзины разложить и вот этот год я
посвящаю именно вот как вы говорите да
финансовому управлению именно хочу прям
всё досконально Да изучить эти
инвестиции чтобы просто в таких в такой
ситуации когда пандемия да или вот такие
события как в январе произошли чтобы ты
спокойно да То есть ты не переживал ты
мог действительно взять и куда-то уехать
и там переждать у казахов есть хорошая
пословица Вот именно к этому событию
что то есть дословно переводится что
золото серебро - это камень
пшеница и ячмень - Это еда Ну насколько
я смог правильно перевести но здесь
сразу хочу ещё второй лайфхак
подсказать Дело в том что вот твоя
потребность в наличных она помимо
безопасности это является ещё и очень
хорошим инструментом управления личными
финансами Я просто рекомендую если у вас
проблем с управле управлением личными
финансами снимите все деньги с к
Закройте Apple Pay откажитесь от
кредитных карчек платите за всё
наличными Поверьте мне когда человек
достаёт наличным и платит у него
психологически совсем другой подход к
деньгам а как хранить деньги Я же говорю
про
небольшие Я же не говорю говорю про
небольшие
ежедневные Да поэтому желательно всё
держать в кэше и рассчитываться в кэше
вопросы бюджетирование это тоже То есть
когда ты карточкой расплатишься
самый главный
лайфхак управление личными финансами
делайте всё так чтобы
платить платить было
сложно Apple Pay кредитные карточки всё
делают облегчает платежи завтра закроют
все свои карточки смотрите Ну у тебя
достаточно доходов поэтому может не это
но смотрите все вот эти
купоны дисконты клубные карты и так
далее Всё Рассчитано только на то чтобы
облегчить вам возможность платить Apple
Pay кредитные карточки и так далее А вы
делаете наоборот максимально усложняйте
Если вы хотите купить какую-то вещь у
вас в кармане оказалось денег Ну значит
сам Аллах вам сказал не покупай эту вещь
но не доставайте кредитную карточку и
Apple Pay платите за всё наличными это
дополнительная проблема ехать домой за
деньгами пока ты съездишь ты уже
передумаешь думаешь зачем мне это
покупать поэтому Ну как бы такой лайфхак
Олжас у тебя А ты вообще Какие ошибки
видишь в управлении
финансами ошибки Ну я бы наверное сейчас
хотел бы рассказать у себя можно вообще
как вот я видел такой мне друг
рассказывал случай очень показатель но
это больше не ошибка наверное А вот как
раз таки вот к финансовой подушке то что
вы говорили да то есть это вот у людей с
юга есть Прямо такая вот
предпринимательская жилка кото бы я вот
хотел бы вот развить в своих детях то
есть и сам где-то Да тоже подкачать эту
жилу да то есть там семья приехала в
Астану То есть получается Мать отец и
по-моему двое или трое сыновей уже
женатые то есть они получается приехали
сняли квартиру и каждый из них вышел на
работу получается и муж и жёны все и
дети то есть все вышли а мать сказала
говорит всю зарплату даёте мне угу всё
получается каждый проходил то есть И вот
сын приносит зарплату дочка приносит
зарплату то есть как бы ну сноха то есть
мы все То есть получается Проходит
какое-то время то есть Она копит Всё это
делает потом через какое-то время
покупает квартиру старшего сыночка потом
начинает копить дальше то есть она нало
чёрной кассы да да Ну типа такого Ну это
семейно уже внутри То есть как бы и она
накапливает на вторую квартиру и таким
образом то есть уже не ждя поддержки от
государства то есть ни каких-то там
помощи там от кого-то просто взяли свою
руку дини усилия направились фокус
поймали то есть и решили Все закрыли
вопрос понятно что не сразу но с
каким-то отсрочкой Да но зато решили то
есть и для меня это был такой очень
показательный пример Как можно То есть
даже в сложных ситуациях объединившись
То есть как бы можно решить то есть
очень большой количество примеров
классный классный лайфхак здесь знаете
такую вещь я скажу вообще есть одна
такая пробле Я заметил такую веь вообще
у
человека Бедного нету понимания такой
ресурсы и бедный человек думает что Да у
меня же ничего нет у меня денег нет На
самом деле у любого человека даже
Бедного особенно молодого бедного
человека слушайте У вас есть Самый
главный ресурс под названием энергия
второй главный ресурс под названием
время третий ресурс - это знания
четвёртый ресурс - это уже деньги это
всё это на последнем То есть у вас есть
куча вещей которые вы можете
конвертировать все ресурсы
конвертируются друг друга соответственно
Вы можете
друго время в деньги энергию в деньги
знания в деньги и так далее и так далее
и здесь возникает следующий Парадокс Я
заметил такую вещь что все бедные люди
не умеют планировать своё время
соответственно я сразу просека когда
человек не умеет планировать своё время
значит он также примерно планирует свои
деньги потому что какая разница какой
ресурс ты планируешь время это тот
который наглядный пример Почему у меня
основной курс это казнь планирование
кода
планиро у него
автоматически налаживается процесс
управления деньгами автоматически Потому
что если ты можешь управлять одним
ресурсом Ты можешь управлять и другим
ресурсом и са самая большая ошибка в
управлении как временем как деньгами Это
я называю проблема опилок Что такое
проблема опилок Интересно что мы когда
планируем сво время мы в течение дня
можем запланировать три крупных дела но
мы не знаем чем заниматься во время
когда здесь Ждём когда едем в дороге
когда ещё 15 минут то есть нам для
выполнения дел нужно вот час минимум А
вот эти 15 минут 10 минут 12 7 8 9 минут
они сгорают сгорают сгорают Мы обычно
это в соцсетях и всё сгорает Но если
брать
совокупности количество опилок влияет
больше на вашу результативность чем
большие дела то есть в ка в казной
технологии есть такое правило самые
большие изменения в вашей жизни
происходят от ежедневных маленьких
изменений то же самое В финансах мы
крупные расходы контролируем а основные
деньги у нас уходят через вот эти мелочи
кофе там воды там там ещё что-то ещё
что-то купил чехол кайфо и вот эти опил
м завтрашнего дня кофе не будет пить
теперь опилки не и эти опилки съедают на
самом
деле проекти финансовою грамотность Ага
опилки сдают очень много ресурсов Даже
те которые мы не подозреваем
Дима Какие ошибки ты вот видишь у себя
или у других Я наверное больше про
ошибки инвестирование бы рассказал
Почему Потому что действительно эта тема
сейчас настолько стала популярной Ну
считать вот за столом все сидят и каждый
на пороге стать инвестором кто-то вот
сейчас только станет кто-то скоро и ведь
на самом деле вот после пандемии когда
был бум IPO по-моему каждый Казахстанец
тоже участвовал бум IPO как раз Freedom
Finance они там на этом хорошо
рекламировали хорошо показывали
результаты и как раз-таки все полезли в
инвестиции тут вот наверное самая
главная проблема с которой столкнутся
каждый Кто пришёл в инвестирование
конечно потеря денег первое что здесь
однозначно Я бы рекомендовал чтобы не
наступить на грабли начните
инвестировать с того что не жалко будет
потерять Да почему Потому что наверняка
первые даже возможно полгода когда вы
начнёте инвестировать Вы ещё и будете
зарабатывать видеть хорошие результаты и
настолько Тонкая грань между инвестором
и азартом что к сожалению в первые
полгода большинство скатываются в этот
Азарт и начинается занимать деньги чтобы
инвестировать Ко мне часто многие
приходят говорят Дим Вот как ты думаешь
что лучше сделать вот кредит досрочно
закрыть или в инвестирование положить Я
же здесь зарабатываю Хорошо как бы ты не
говорил всё равно люди любят учиться на
своих ошибках они всё равно кладут в
инвестирование всё теряют а потом была
возможность погасить досрочно кредит А
хотя Ну опять же простой пример если ты
досрочно можешь погасить кредит и там на
3-4 года ты экономишь по
18-20 про годовых то есть чтобы в рынке
заработать 18-20 про за год надо
попотеть О это даже я скажу это
маловероятно вот это люди не понимают то
есть Гася быстрее кредит нежели
вкладывать кредитные деньги то есть
выгоднее закрыть кредит Конечно потом
есть т я хочу глав ошибки что в
инвестировании не всё так легко не так
как показывается в рекламах на фильмах
что гаранти вот как будто бы если ты
начнешь инвестировать что ты будешь
меньше
работать или вот знаете как я почему я
вот хочу сейчас всё это Изучить и
инвестировать чтобы через 10 лет Когда
мне будет там 50 лет чтобы у меня была
там куча акций Да и я просто получала
сво
здесь просто и желаю такой же жизни это
сначала у вас такое желание но когда вы
попадаете в мир инвестирования вам
захочется уже вы забудете Что вы хотите
через 10 лет у вас начнётся блин тут вот
человек 20% за оди день за ночь
заработал вы начнёте туда погружаться и
все ваши вот эти десятилетние планы они
просто будут стираться нет Там же есть
брокеры Freedom Фин они же будут меня
консультировать ещё раз брокер - это тот
Он зарабатывает вы покупаете продаёте
Никогда не слушайте
бает шикарную фразу сказал говорит
вообще улл срит ну там где все брокеры
Да это такое место говорит Куда люди
приезжают на метро и где обучают люди
которые приехали на метро обучают тех
кто приехал на на ро устройст обучают
тех кто приехал на рол срос То есть если
бы брокеры были крутые в инвестировании
то они бы вас не обучали инвести что
делать тогда нам вот мы сейчас с
нурланом активно работаем
зарабатываем учиться учи
Опять куда нам инвестировать деньги
кстати не самый плохой
вариант в долларах или в евро Ну в юанях
Я не знаю в чём хранится то здесь я
единственное что вот чтобы от ошибок
ограничить в первую очередь лучше гасите
кредит а не инвестируйте второе Не
считайте что вы оседлали рынок когда это
рано или поздно придёт Ну и скорее всего
что первые ваши инвестиции вы потеряете
Вот наверное Ну просто к этому надо быть
готом что
касается первые вторые и третие
потеряете если у вас не будет
знаний сказал так насчёт рисков на
фондовом рынке он вообще сказал так
самый главный риск на фондовом рынке -
это
невежество невежество и а хуже этого
невежества есть другой риск это когда А
что такое невежество он говорит когда
инвестор не ведает что творит хуже этого
это когда
инвет это одно но когда он не знает и
думает что знает Вот это хуже когда он
не знает и думает что знает большинство
начинающих инвесторов первоначальные
знания там от этого услышал От этого от
этого И он уже думает о блин нормально
там особенно если на рынке а рынок он
как казино он коварный зависит от твоего
психологического типа Бывает так что раз
раз серия выигрышей и ты всё попал и у
тебя вот эта сама уверенность потом ты
делаешь крупную ставку и в момент когда
ты сдела крупную ставку всё именно
рушится Я сам очень долго торговал на
рынке огромными суммами огромными
суммами А я так скажу я знаю что такое
боль Я знаю что такое А сколько
максимально вы потеряли А у меня были
дни когда я зафиксировал рекорд Я в день
терял по 3 3.700 000 долларов в день
3.700 000 мой портфель проседать на
3.700 000 долларов в день И самое
главное я выдержал серию в 22 млн
долларов 22 млн долларов я месяц я
просто терял месяц нет А почему вы не
остановились Ну можно же было всегда
вытащить Не потому что я понимал что я
правильную ставку сделал и рынок
восстановится и так далее но это это
должна быть дыхалка это должна быть
дыхалка то есть у тебя когда есть
дыхалка смотри 22 млн долларов потери
это кажется страшно 3,7 млн в день это
вообще кажется страшно Но если у тебя
портфель большой
это же относительно портфеля поэтому но
физически Ты прямо чувствуешь прямо
физическую боль про нам сложно Как бы
вас понять немы не Представляем на самом
деле не эта сумма тоже относительная ты
22 мл Если бы у меня на карточке было 22
млн
Неде Начни терять там по 100.000 долла Я
вообще просто пошла на депозит положила
бы и лежала бы на пляж все все именно
задним числом такие умные все задним
числом такие умные но реально боль
потерь на фондовом рынке она Физическая
боль просто Физическая боль
поэтому очень страшно поэтому нельзя
заниматься инвестированием если у тебя
нет знаний знания - это основа А когда у
тебя уже появятся знания тогда уже ты
решишь заниматься или не заниматься Вот
это очень важный момент нун Какие ошибки
финансовой грамотности Ты у себя
замечаешь либо у других людей в
государстве как сказать Я ещё раз скажу
что я не такой бизнесмен финансист и ты
всё прибедняйся прибедняйся Блин нет Да
я
конечно вот будет подкаст про скромность
я тебя позову всё хорошо Ну конечно я
работаю так чтобы было рентабельно
потому что если ты работаешь и всё
тяп-ляп Это конечно как сказать
неправильная энергия ты сам устоишь вот
этого конечно я всё считаю Но я прочитал
что например я снимал фильм в Турции Для
чего там пригласил дорогих актёров там
большая локация ВС весь труд а цдо
переживал за этот фильм потому что это
пятая часть я хотел каждый год обновлять
э рекорд не из-за денег а просто чтобы
была Вот такая для меня тоже о мотивация
да И у меня тоже Мотивация была чтобы
Голливуд перестал здесь забирать деньги
имеется в виду должны появляться
казахские фильмы которые де здесь остава
для этого надо создавать такую мотивацию
Ну типа Нурлан заработал значит я тоже
заработаю и Много людей будет в этом
бизнесе и для меня хорошо потому что
будет конкуренция и мы
э сейчас просто вас слушаю думаю что
рассказать вот мне было больно когда я 2
года ждал примеры своего фильма пандемия
заканчивается там более-менее до
кинотеатры открылись я выпускаю 30
декабря но из-за того что в государстве
нету правильной идеологии правильно
разделение богатства Я не знаю Да я
сейчас не хочу в политику ходить и там
это уже не модно сейчас их обсуждать
сейчас очень правильно сейчас со стороны
идёт ветер что всё меняется Да куда но
на тот момент случилось то что случилось
и все кинотеатры закрыты торговый центр
закрыты и я да переживаю чтобы главное
чтобы басам босо чтобы государство всё
процветало то что я потерял деньги Ну
потом заработаю но всё равно Факт есть
факт Я оказывается Хоть я буду финансово
грамотной пройду очень много курсов
там не от меня зависело вот эта ситуация
и мне очень дома я сидел дома и мне было
очень больно потому что именно эта пятая
часть бизнес проса Турции Она шла как Ну
даже с кинотеатра звонили говорили что
такого старта не было после тхуна чабор
цду где билетов нет а ажиотаж такой и я
думаю Вот это этот фильм должен был 6
января побить Коре неделю должен был
побить до того был как спрос Несмотря на
то что есть Человек паук там кинс другие
этот конкуренты И в этот момент я дома
сидел всё происходит Конечно я во благо
чтобы государство успокоил всё нормально
было но всё равно как это
ужасно Да это лично единственный не то
что бизнес это то что я занимаюсь 20 лет
юмором и это только на позитиве на
позитиве зарабатывает в Казахстане где
19 млн людей это очень сложно чтобы юмор
продать или там упаковать этот юмор это
очень сложно Мы один из первых кто
начали продавать юмор в Казахстане для
телевидения для корпоративов цду мы её
сделали Так что люди им нужен был этот
да продукт И в этот момент
э я теряю очень много я это сейчас
переживаю Вот вспоминаю Я же знаю как
сколько жене обещаю что будет завтра всё
классно вау Всё Вот это будет Вот это
всё поменяем после Нет сейчас если
запустить может быть после этого
подкаста люди тебя просто поддержат Ну
не то что здесь люди Да и так-то я хочу
поблагодарить всех зрителей они даже
меня отмечают сторис Говорят мы пришли
Нурлана поддержать третий раз пришли
вдвоём пришли с мамой пришли с бабушкой
пришли я вижу поддержку я вижу что они
хотят чтобы я там выровнял Но есть
другие фильмы есть законы киноиндустрии
выходит сейчас новый
фильм Да кин там день луны им тоже
должны сеансы давать кино
за эти сеансы они забирают у бизнес
показа это
жизнь после какого-то времени через 3
недели бизнес пога всё равно уменьшается
хоть люди хотят поддержать но там нету
сеанса уже поэтому я Какой вывод Поэтому
лучше бы в акции Теслы
вложил в
акции и это в этот момент не то что я
просто жалко что в этой
стране тяжело заниматься делом име
виду очень тяжело я вот например 20 лет
занимаюсь только юмором когда я играл 15
лет КВН мои друзья остановились там
работали в банке то всё там где-то
устроились Ну карьерный рост видишь И
каждый раз встречаешься А я до сих пор
Добрый вечер Я это мне это было
нормально Мне нравилась эта игра мне
нравилась КВН я вотще КВН классная игра
он много не помните Я вообще вместе с
вами в кв не участвовал когда учился в
Москве то есть у вас был как раз номер
какой-то вот и вот массовке мы там
пробегали да то есть мы
всегда со студенческих времён всегда вас
поддерживали поэтому и то что вы делаете
на самом деле то есть это вы же первый
открыватель можно сказать да то есть это
очень сложно трудно в какой-то момент
это весело когда тебе 25 23 но когда ты
уже Женился двое детей там дети в школу
идут их надо учить там какие-то курсы и
ты сам тоже какой-то бегал бегал ты
какой-то момент же хочешь же машину
поменять уже старая но думаешь я сейчас
машину на это железо потеряю там 170.000
долларов ну ладно на старом Лекси буду
ездить потому что ну не машина красит
человек ну дело там Да его действие по
ез на старой машине но Севе дал слово
что теперь буду думать имеется в виду я
к чему вёл то что не то что государство
плохое или это то что я всегда думал что
идеология есть кто-то за меня работает
так в этом государстве что я должен
снимать кино и развлекать людей
оказывается за меня никто не думает
имеется в виду а имеется виду и за мою
семью вы не думаете получается я не могу
вам доверять имеется в виду нету вот
этого Как
сказать стабильности То есть когда есть
индустрия вы просто снимаете продукт и
он уходит А вам то есть помимо того что
снимать продукт ещё и индустрию как бы
по особено мне кажется тяжело что после
пандемии вроде пандемия
закончилась Да вроде бы Закончилась И
уже можно было да выходи Интере все
вроде бы соскучились Да у меня были
какие-то Финанс вложи в три фильма снял
бизнес Турции потом снял продолжение
бизнес Турции кото называется скоро
выйдет марте и снял ещё один фильм для
турецкого рынка который называется Мета
на турецком языке с турецкими актёрами я
там чуть-чуть сыграл но как продюсер Я
на эти три фильма вкладываю начинается
вот это ВС пандемия Вот это ВСС и оно
всё замораживается все деньги в
компьютере
жжж и опять вот это момент который 5 лет
назад дочка Дат свою копил шли нуно
слава богу есть друзья они там по
разговорам чувствуют иногда закидывают
Ну ладно вот те 2Т или там находят
какую-то рекламу какой-то компании ладно
здесь я вижу они мне помогают но всё
равно я опять в этот момент попал но
учитывая что я снимаю кассовые фильмы
там не знаю н студия тоже был
рейтинговый КВН тоже имеется в виду по
то что я делаю считаю что до конца делаю
ц КВН играет до конца до конца
телевидение сделали Так что Ну президент
по на диван там кино снимаем остановили
Голливуд Да ну вот это всё так Куп взять
Я понял что я неправильно финансовы
неграмотные потому что всё идёт
правильно какие-то на каждой индустрии
ты доходишь потолка но всё равно дочка
приносит свою копилку и что делать рла
кович в такие моменты вот человек делает
ну классные продукты Да я сейчас сам
хочу до конца довести то что
я э стадию перел не обижаться имеется в
виду себя
анализи не обижаться на кого-то кто
стане или кто-то кто-то виноват Нет я
просто сил дома я виноват здесь должно
быть и работа то что ты любишь и чтобы
она приносила правильный доход име вду
как то что говорили не все яй там в
одной корзине А я же только творчеством
занимаюсь у меня нет дополнительных там
компаний И теперь я вот себе даже сейчас
как сказать цель поставил себ считаю ото
мне больше там не юморист не там Угу
прикольчик там не знаю Да мне больше
получается вот Африку организовать там
Америку оет Это ц увидеть к чему это
придёт Угу я вот Это думаю вот э формула
аналитику как бы сейчас я поменяю Угу
имеете в виду теперь какой-то бизнес и
чтобы я там хочу вот это как сказать
использовать опыт блок туры короче будет
блок туры теперь будут Да вот например
даже в инвестициях в инвестициях вот я
хочу я новичок не то что новичок даже
слово новичок там рано говорит ещ там да
и я купил всего две акти наверно да Если
так крупно говорить не крупно вот
внимание очень большое было это ульм Хил
который вырос 10 раз в августе потом я
посмотрел imc это imc терте который
владеет большое количество кинотеатров в
Америке они сильно упали потому что
пандеми именно били на кинотеатры я так
всё открывается автобусы полные базары
полные
кинотеатр я так думаю что во время типа
этой пандемии нельзя веселиться
Да я думал вот этот кинотеатр самый
последний Выйдет он на дне кто-то
какой-то бизнес уже возрождает самолёт
уже начинает летать Я думаю вот надо Е
купить он стоил доллар 97 думаю а он
стоил до пандемии 78 долларов ю 34 ра
вырастет и там не не большие суммы
сейчас скажу маленькие суммы
вложился и он вырос до
22 потом в апреле он вырос до 77
супер но опять же я Продал то что было
потому что у меня нужда была да потому
что
баж чуть-чуть заработал
продал две-три акции которые я сам
предвидел и и это лайфхак или нет Я
перестал читать новости имеется в виду
кто-то говорит р там подписал
миллиардные контракты на весь мир тос
тос смотрю фаер вообще не растёт стоял
на одном меся 1-д доллара пом Почему
смотрю уже всё Файер начали
вакцинировать почему он не растёт А все
вкладывают fer там Apple Apple тоже
чуть-чуть вырастет упадёт смотрю модерна
она
летает там с до этого до 50 за 2 года я
говорю о модер это
игрок любом Я очень футбол люблю Ставки
не делаю но очень много друзья там
говорят за столом сидят ради азарта
сегодня Реал выиграет я го Откуда ты
знаешь невозможно если Реал Барселона
играет очень большая концентрация на эти
э на эту игру по всему миру значит если
люди все будут стоять они сейчас 0
сделают это выгодно
ходить я также Смотрю на эти
здесь модер прыгает и Я так понял что
есть игра вся жизнь игра я решил новости
не читать что Трамп сказал что этот гори
это всё игра ФРС там что-то сделал сесс
и он вырос не по правилам там был Т там
какой-то шум был
большой Я к тому что и в кино тоже есть
такая формула мне говорили бизнес понад
когда часть снима Не зайдёт я говорю
почему не зайдёт он говорит Ну
во-первых казах язычная име нет
аудитории в городах А все кинотеатры в
городах и ты должен снимать
там другой фильм Я говорю Нет я хочу
снимать именно на этого зрителя Я выбрал
зрителя он не подвёл имеется в
виду такое
ведение инвестиция Да я вот такой знаю
не лайфхак но интуиция имее виду это
большое движение Я не представляю вот у
мне один Был звонок когда пандемия
началась норвежцы продали все
европейские эти акции и начинают
вкладывать в американские я начал я тоже
новичок смотрю американские больше упали
чем другие компании например americans
Airlines United Airlines смотрю Чем
люган упал 10-1 раз и весь норвежский
вот этот фонд уходит туда я думаю
Норвегия это тся что-то умные что-то они
кстати выиграли 10 разн сам с собой
совещаются
у него такой консилиум самим собой а я
Почему думал что футбол типа надо
футбольные акции покупать футбол
вернётся потому что в мае пошёл слух что
принц адман купилка собирается купить
нека во время пандемии когда мы в Алмате
дома сидели я говор он принц он за
где-то при власти него есть Като новость
наверно какая-то меня сделать и он
покупает у слух по что он купит во время
пандемии когда нельзя собираться целый
стадион Я говорю Нет я с вами име я не в
массовой СМИ име лю кажется хороший
потенциал я начал вот этои изучать и он
вс-таки купил не я вот хотел вот узнать
Вот в тот момент когда вот вы же сняли
Деги есть а потом он вырос есть
а вот было какой больше преобладание
ощущения эмоций то что вы вс-таки
заработали или вс-таки недо
заработали не да заработал я считал уже
как сказал что я считал эти деньги уже
что это мои уже это были
мои Знаете есть такой психологический
синдром что кстати сейчас Олимпиада в
Пекине
идёт так вот самое интересное что вот
место да первое место второе место
третье место
а выяснилось психологически подтверждено
что самым не несчастливым себя чувствует
тот кто занял второе место не там не сям
Да нет потому что он про себя думает
Блин ещ чуть-чуть бы я был бы первым
чуть-чуть бы я был бы первым а самым
счастливым чувствует себя третье место
Почему Потому что он говорит блин я
вошёл в тройку
я я вошёл в тройку из всей этой толпы я
вошёл я попал в тройку понимаете Поэтому
вот у тебя синдром это как раз второго
места когда ты говоришь блин мог бы но
это инвестиции это на самом деле я так
как долго профессионально занимался
инвестициями нужно чётко понимать что а
вот как в том анекдоте не путайте туризм
с иммиграцией да А у вас у всех
романтическое представление об
инвестици
пляж пляж ноутбук там
это акции футбольны гда ничего не делаем
и так далее на самом деле у меня есть
такой маркер как только тебя инвестиция
начинает возбуждать либо ты часто
смотришь начинаешь на графики смотреть
то всё скорее всего ты попадёшь потому
что в этой жизни есть главные
правила за всё что тебе приносит
удовольствие платить должен
ты за всё что приносит удовольствие
платить должен ты Поэтому если
инвестиции для тебя это рутинный
Ежедневный труд то скорее всего ты там
будешь зарабатывать если инвестиции для
тебя весело фан азартно то скорее всего
ты будешь там терять Это как в анекдоте
про
чукчу Я ничего не имею против чук Я к
ним очень хорошо отношусь но такой
анекдот Советский когда Чукча приехал в
Москву Заработал деньги там на золотишко
или на чём-то на бивни мамонта взял
проститутку зашёл в номер сделал своё
дело заплатил 100 долларов и выходит
проститка думает Блин классный чувак
куча денег наверное с Севера приехал Ну
не наверное точно я его сейчас раскрути
и говорит Чукча Чукча подожди не уходи
давай ещё раз Чукча Говорит хорошо раз
сделал второй раз своё дело берёт свои
100 долларов с тумбочки на тумбочку
положил раз забрал в карман и уходит
говорит Э ты что ты что ты
мне 200 дол говорит он почему говорит Ну
мы же два раза Он говорит А что нету
дурак я хотел я платил ты хотела ты
платил на так и так и в инвестициях один
к одному Если вы получаете удовольствие
Азар и так далее платите в общем нужно
каждый рубль зарабатывать
мо вот вот это вот это очень правильная
мысль Динара что любые деньги надо
зарабатывать даже в инвестициях это
тяжёлый труд Я в своё время например а
что деньги не получаются Вот то есть
энергия денег Она не любит да такую
лёгкость фан А смотрите бывает это такие
случайные отклонения но я называю
существует два типа везения один тип
Слепое везение второй закономерное
везение а основная мысль нужно вам
достичь уровня закономерного везения
Когда время работает на вас Ну как бы
что бы не происходило всё работает вашу
пользу так вот смотрите случайное
везение Слепое везение оно может прийти
к любому человеку мы не можем никак
управлять никак этим не можем управлять
любому из нас может в какой-то момент
повести так же как и не
повести То есть это слепой случай А есть
закономерный закономерный случай - это
как правило я вот у меня есть
определение успеха это когда возможность
встречается с
подготовленностью чем больше у человека
подготовленности тем больше возможностей
Он видит и тем больше шансов что он эти
возможности использует свою пользу
поэтому я молодым людям говорю больши
удача - это подготовленность да А нет
это когда подготовленность с
возможностью встречаются А я молодым
людям часто говорю большинство молодых
людей 99% первым делом Начинает бегать и
искать возможности Я говорю возможности
как река каждый день приходит проблема
вашей неподготовленность это как
восхождение на гору когда ты обучаешься
по мере восхождения на гору у тебя
большие виды открываются
там го и и идёшь у тебя больше
возможностей открываются поэтому
работать надо не над поиском
возможностей это всё равно что на равни
считаться далеко посмотреть бессмысленно
ты поднимись на гору увидишь больше
соответственно надо работать над своей
подготовленностью это основа
и мы наверно плавно Подходим к
завершению сегодня тако хоро бе бы все
темы если можно ещё вот хотел Вот как
раз про ошибки просто я не успел сказать
вы переключились на Диму вот Одна из
таких ошибок которые Вот как раз таки
вот инвестирование то есть именно брать
если не только эту жизненную и вечную я
понял то что вот я раньше мало занимался
благотворительностью и то что Вот есть
такой история рассказывает То есть у
одного очень богатого человека
спрашивает как вы стали таким богатым
прям очень богатым он говорит я
соревновался с Аллахом
говорит как ну говорит Сначала я дал
говорит потом Он дал потом я дал говорит
потом Он дал потом я дал потом он дал и
он выиграл
говорит это есть тако хороший Хадис это
действительно в этом есть большое
большое значение и здесь Давайте
подытоживая сегодняшнюю передачу мы
сегодня поговорили К
сожалению масштабы или формат любой
передачи недостаточно для того чтобы
осветить все аспекты вот эти это большая
тема на самом деле
делаем такой показ 8
часов 5
ча можем говорить до слуша
[музыка]
сегодня большая Тема мы со всех сторон
пощупай эту тему
потрогаю какие-то полезные мысли вы
извлекли мы сегодня рассказали много
личных историй каждый поделился своими
личными историями и как взаимоотношения
его с финансами выстраиваются было много
Я надеюсь полезного для вас и напоследок
как закрывашка по нашей традиции Я
наверное дам вам ещё один такой или
серию
лайфхаков Вот то котором можно применить
хоть
завтра смотрите вообще я вам рекомендую
так как управлять личными финансами
Проблема в том что люди говорят что у
меня маленькая зарплата большая зарплата
и так далее абсолютно не имеет значения
пусть хоть у вас зарплата хоть 30.000
тег хоть 50.000 хоть 60 хоть 60 млн это
правило в принципе работает везде Ну
Особенно для людей у которых маленькие
доходы Первое
правило всем с 10% я называю это налог
на будущее всегда откладывать 10%
сначала
сначала проблема большинства людей в том
что они сначала тратят а потом
пытаются сэкономленное отложить так не
работает сначала нужно заплатить налог
самому себе будущему 10% второе - это
налог на Безопасность это ещё 10% это
когда вы покупаете страховки то есть
обязательно происходят какие-то
несчастные случаи или непредвиденные
ситуации Поэтому нужно создавать свой
страховой фонд вот 20% у вас улетело
Почему именно цифра 20 это не только
вопрос законо пота Дело в том что есть
обширные исследования в том же гарварде
по-моему
проводились где было доказано что
20% расходов человека абсолютно ничего
не значит которого мог легко отказаться
бы легко Это то что Ну будем тать низко
висящие плоды легко может отказаться так
вот Вы сделайте наоборот
поставьте налог Заплатите 10% самому
себе второе 10% сформируйте страховой
фонд это то что неприкосновенно 10% вы
можете инвестировать А 10% - это лучше
покупайте страховки либо держите в кэше
то что вот сегодня Динара говорил но
подальше от себя то есть надо от себя
оградить на третьем месте Это я считаю
жизненные расходы это продукты питания
это Одежда это обучение детей Ну то что
без чего вы не можете жить то есть
коммунальные расходы Там и так далее это
на третьем месте На четвёртом месте это
крупные покупки А вернее вру на
четвёртом месте качество жизни Угу до
крупных покупок качество жизни смотрите
после того как вы закрыли жизненные
потребности не снижайте качество жизни
то
ходите в кино видишь Угу спасибо вате
себя ходите в кино ходите в театр то
есть
не это одна из Больших ошибок когда люди
начинают экономить они прежде всего
начинают экономить на качестве жизни
когда вы экономите на качестве жизни
сразу же начинает падать ваша внутренняя
самооценка и
самоуважение только ваша самооценка и
самово жения упадёт вы начнёте
зарабатывать меньше это то что ты в
начале говорила что я трачу Я начинаю
зарабатывать больше Потому что ты
Повышаешь свою самооценку самоуважение
ты относишься к себе как Королеве
соответственно доходы начинают расти ты
начинаешь смотрите свойство самооценки
самоуважения не в том что ты начинаешь
от мира требовать больше самой основной
Хак в том что от высокой самооценки и
самоуважения ты начинаешь более
требовательным быть к себе а это значит
вовремя выполнять взятые на себя
обязательства выполнять как можно больше
дел
качеству требований выше вот то что ты
говоришь можно снимать в октау фильм про
Африку А можно ехать туда потому что
важно Это опять то как ты сам себя
оцениваешь сам Себя уважаешь ты для тебя
это непозволительно снять про Африку в
Талгаре потому что ну это не уважение к
твоему зрителю к себе там и так далее
Поэтому вот на четвёртом месте не
снижайте качество жизни Вот повторюсь
заплати ло себе будущему дальше
страховка дальше жизненные расходы без
того без чего вы не можете просто
физически это не ваш выбор дальше
качество жизни и на пятом месте - это
уже крупные покупки как машина там ещё
что-то на пятом месте и дальше на шестом
всё что вы сэкономите здесь вкладывайте
в своё будущее то есть Вдруг вы здесь
сэкономили и опять опять Пускай это
будет не 10-15 про и таким образом вы
постепенно выберетесь из этой Ну не
скажу нищеты но из этой ситуации и тогда
вы начнёте управлять а своей жизнью
начнёте управлять одним из своих
ресурсов под названием деньги а вообще э
Теперь если брать об инвестиции об этом
больше всего вопрос возникает типа я
коплю всего 10% у меня же ещё мало денег
куда инвестировать я вам скажу
инвестируйте безошибочно в саморазвитие
безошибочно саморазвитие инвестируйте до
тех пор пока вы не поймёте что вы у вас
уже благодаря саморазвитию увеличились
доходы и у вас уже есть деньги для того
чтобы инвестировать в другие вещи в
акции облигации депозиты
бла-бла-бла-бла-бла
именно об управлении своей энергией и
своим временем научитесь управлять своей
энергией это главный ваш ресурс
научитесь управлять своим временем это
второй главный ваш ресурс А деньги - это
это это потом приобретайте третий ресурс
знания и когда вы управляете своей
энергией временем и у вас есть ресурс
под названием знания деньги придут
автоматически как Побочный продукт вашей
эффективной деятельности Вот мои
пожелания вам всем гостям нашим Всем
большое спасибо за такую содержательную
беседу э мне самому понравился очень
понравился подкаст Может быть потому что
мне тема близка Может быть потому что вы
поняли да что вам нужно срочно запускать
курс потому что даже мы может быть не
уме Может быть потому что вы
потенциально мои клиенты а но на самом
деле потому что вы приятные хорошие люди
которых я знаю в жизни и не только по
подкасту А за пределами подкаста поэтому
вам большое спасибо вам огромное спасибо
вам друзья Э пожалуйста проявляйте свою
реакцию лайкайте комментируйте нажимайте
колокольчики что там ещё об этом говорят
Ну короче до встречи на следующих
подкастах
[музыка]